[Music]
Oh
k
[Music]
Oh
T
[Music]
and
oh
[Music]
h
and
[Music]
T
Oh
sad there is more JC happening in
Latin America there are representatives here
there are representatives of the gcov of chile
of the JC of Mexico events that are going to
continue carrying this legacy in everything
which is the region and obviously there is a
large number of local communities that
I invite you so that you can
contact medellí js Bogotá js
Barranquilla other groups that are
also doing events and not to mention
soon We have news that
next year some community said to create
a conference like this or even more
great that would be the most
wonderful for those who don't know me
My name is Juliá Duque and today I will be
your host today
some parish notices before
start for all those who have
requested devices
interpretation Remember that when
are going to go, they have to deliver them to
get your ID back yesterday
two people left with a device
we keep your ID with your
driving license if stopped
police well it's going to be a problem that doesn't
we want you to have because
we want here remember don't you don't know
they forget to take the device
they deliver outside to be returned
the ID lost objects Right now we
We found a cell phone and there have been
little things that are being lost
security people you have them
They see them that are at the doors
They are in charge of issues
lost objects you approach them
They ask, did I miss this and they already
They are in charge of doing the process of
return take care of your belongings
because we also want everyone to go out
very happy here now yes
we had told yesterday that always
we have production problems
last minute and it's time to deploy and
It's time to improvise to be able to
give you the best
experience and unfortunately we had
a speaker who could not travel due to issues
government regulations
that bother a lot and from Brazil this
speaker could not travel due to a
vaccine unfortunately she is not here
accompanying us physically but we have it
virtual So I'm going to give it to her
the introduction if you can put it in for me
screen she is Jessica phelix She
He comes from Brazil and is an expert in everything
what is the issue of optimization and
performance then the talk of her
It will be in English and
optimization perform analysis of
javascript applications please
applause
J Thank you very much Jessica.
listening here I'm going to tell her
which can
start yes I am
listening thank you there
listening Okay Hello Can you call me J
because as a latin girl the only one
person who calls me by my name
complete is my mother when she fights
with me I want to be saying that this
It's my first international conference
and that you in the audience and the
JSC organization are part of the
historic moment in my life I had
problems with my flight and I can't be there
in person but I ask for your understanding and
don't sleep I promise it will be
funny okay
So let's switch to english
and before talking
perform Let bic How javascript Life
cycle works this will be Our foundation
to better understand and perform
issues and This is the I think the most
important thing is understand the basis
well the First Step in the Life cycle of
javascript the javascript application is
loading the javascript source code and
here is the process of the browser
Download a javascript file when you find
a Script tag in the html code or When
event stringer javascript code is
activated the Download is initiated by
the browser through antp request to the
server Host in javascript file Which
Will respond with the file Download by
the browser and cache it for
late Okay and the next Step is analyzing
the sece code and here is When the Magic
happens the brows created an abstract
syntax Tree to represent the structure
of the code and this process evol the
browser in the source code and construct
this as Like You can see in this image
Just of curiosity This is an abstract
syntax and This is a hierarchical
representation of the code syntax
enabling fur analysis and
interpretation Okay Uh What is next
Step compiling the se code content for
Machine code well What exactly is
Machine code and What is happened the
browser javascript compiler convert
javascript source code which is in this
Side I am not good with left and right
Because I can write with both hands So
The High Level Language is When we
started and this process of copulation
refers to translating human readable
source code like javascript into Machine
executable coach which is a low Level
set of instructions that cpu can understand
and execute So The Machine code is When
the robot is
pointing Okay the next Step is When the
browsers Start to optimize the code
and this process um compile this Sorry
the browser can javascript can compile
and optimize the generate code to improve
an application performance including some
techniques like function and lining that
code elimination and Loop elimination
there are a bunch of amazing things
that javascript compiler do but I will
show Just One thing Okay um here We have
a very simple function that Take two
arguments and we hope there are numbers
but we cannot guarantee as There is not
typ Script in the code and we and we add
or concatenate these two
values ​​next we call this function in Our
code with two
and Now Let see What the process do
Under the
H Ok In The process optimization One of
the things that happen in the function
Call is replaced by the by current Body
at cile Time this can reduce the program
Run Time at eliminate the overhead of the
function calls and the allocation of
memory for local variables however
important to
not functions can be in l and some
functions May be too large or to complete
to be inine This is just a simple
example of How powerful is this
javascript
compilers Ok Now optimization code is
done the next Step is create the main
object and PR and global scope And I
don't explain this too much Because I
need
another another I forgot the word I need
another 30 minutes to do this so not this
this Will happen and after this we Start
to execute in the code and important
part of the javascript lifest
application is the event
management click Buttons or execute some
actions and after all this We have the
end of execution so This is the big
picture
of how cy javascript works although we
have many steps in this process And I
give more emphasis to the performance
Part And I want to bring attention to
the machines responsible for
optimization that we don't see but we
can feel in Our code and This is the
javascript Run Times just a matter of
curiosity v8 is Used in Google Chrome
and other chrum bas browsers Spider
monkey is Used in mozilla
firefox chra Is Us in Microsoft Ed and
javascript Core is Used in Apple sa Okay
Now we understand How the compilers in
How the javascript and and browsers and
all this kind of Stuff works When we
First execute the javascript code Ok Now
Now take a Look at some code techniques
to optimize the code Because the
compiler cannot do Everything for Us we
need to help so I will show you some
code techniques that Will help to
achieve some interest and performance
game as long As you use then correctly
this Part doesn't have many moving gifts
and is more conceptual I promise it will
be brief and
explanation Okay let's Start by
analyzing this code Uh Maybe the Front
enders understanding this better I tried
to put examples of frontend and backend
in this Talk so When A image enter in
the viewer in the Data sece attribute
and set as the sech attribute causing an
image load in the browser does not
Support interaction observable for
example a fallback is provided to load
the images immediately and What is the
name of this l loading l loading is a
that involves loading content only When
requested by the user to improve the
performance of a web page and but It's
important to understand there are some
scenarios that using laser is not a good
idea for example When above the fold
content is important and needs to be loaded
as quick as possible above fold is the
part of the screen that you don't need
to roll up to
see other other scenario There is not
recommend us
When the content is small and does not
significantly affect the page loading
Time and When the content is necessary
for user interaction with the
page so not is not the the answer for
Our problems of
performance the Second example is the
bouncing the bouncing is a technique
very interesting And I put
this clock Because
you can execute the function Just One
time in interval of Time so It's very
Great and help Us a lot but there are
some problems we do not use the bouncing
When working with events that need to be
executed immediately such as typing in
and put Field for example and we When we
delay the function for execute can
negatively affect the program
performance so Take care with use of the
bouncing and The Last tip is web workers
web workers are javascript Api they
allow Us to Run the Script to separate
threads from the browser from the main
thread improve the performance of the
web applications and Okay seems like
Amazing and It's very Amazing but there
are some problems When you know not when
you do not use web workers When the code
is not heavy enough to justify the use
of web workers This is important and
When the Support for web workers is not
available in All the browsers That web
application needs to Support there's
something very important to take a look
and Finally When the use of web workers
May introduces Data synchronization
issues between the main trad and the
secondary trad and As you can see there
are Amazing techniques but If we don't
have sure that they are true necessary for
code we May have Uh huge
problems Ok uh uh Just Let me make ask
you here does anyone here use Pure
javascript and
applications someone I cannot see but
iust in you I think It's very
difficult it can be done but I think
It's for few people usually We have to
deal with many libraries and Services in
all that can completely Impact in the
performance so remember that you do not
Just Look at the javascript performance
but all your full application
performance and the libraries and
etc Uh the more libraries the more
complexity the more performance problems
therefore it is important to understand the
perform work also involve
understanding the tradeoffs of the
project stack and can bring and deal
with All the best
so Okay as I need to pay attention with
javascript performance and All the
things That I use in my application but
How do I do
this Okay um There is a very common m in
brazil in Tech Community on Twitter orx
that say to that to if you wanted to
show that you are a senior developer
Just say it depends to all questions is
the answer
perfect
Ok seriously Now let's look for someone
specific example of possibility
performance issues that done that do not
involve javascript directly I will only
mention one for a sake of Time What do
you think is the biggest potential
performance problems When user
react Okay Let me take some Seconds to
you think
anyone have some
idea I have a personal opinion And I
think the most performance
problems in area use react no I'm just
kidding react is incredible to however
it needs to be used correctly to bring
the best result Just like angular View
or even
javascript but now talking seriously Uh
One of the possible performance problems
that we can deal with rea is
rendering rendering occurs When A
component State chang causing All the
descend from the component to render by
the This behavior is specific to react
mechanism and This is more This is very
important to give attention This is not
a javascript problem I am not a react
hater
but This is can be This is can be said
This is not a javascript Problem um Ok
but how we can monitor this Problem and
This is something very important When we
work with performance understanding
javascript und understanding the
tradeoffs of all the libraries and Part
that is involved with Our code but
understand How to use the best Tools
and There is Amazing to build for react
There is reacted Tools the reacted
developer to this example I use in
Chrome developer Tools but this
extinction works in another browsers um
is an Open source Uh tool from react and
it allows developers to inspect the
react component hierarchies edit prompts
and States Andy performance problems and
This is the recording of component that
we call to Why this this render so if
you need to take a check on How much
your compose is rendering here
rendering this Will help Us a lot And I
have another example and Do You remember
Lazy load That I talk in the Start of
the Talk okay So with the rea react dev
Tools you can check the time and all the
kind of stuff that you want to see to Uh
make sure that you Focus on the right
Problem and fix this as quickly as
possible This is an Amazing Amazing to
and as we Talk about developer Tools Uh Let
I introduced myself to the performance monitor Uh
this This is Amazing to are providing
more Advanced memory management for
example and one common problem When we
Look at performance is Memory leaks and
if you use this performance monitor by
recording Uh the time of your
application is running we can visualize
and analyze the performance of the
page so use the Us The Book theb Tools
it is very very useful and help you to fix
some Memory problems Memory leaking
issues but there
depends
Because It's very very to monitoring
Just One required
And requs requisition sorry There is a
difference to monitor Run requisition
and H requisitions When we monitor only
one request the Impact of the
performance is minimal and as the System
just handling a light workload however
When we monitor More Than request the
System May Face overload to the
increased workload Which can lead to
delays with Proc and request and
possible scalable issues well increase
the number of monitor request can
overload the event Loop affect in the
overall performance of the application
so there are problems very very
different and as I say Always it
depends So let's take a look some
Amazing to help you to can deal with
this huge problems the First one is
autocan and autocan is a low testing to
Used To simulate High amount of web
Traffic and measure service performance
this to generate complicated testing
scenarios and provide good measurements
in development environment and
performance
labs really This is an Amazing to And
Yo
feel Sorry This is an Amazing And I
Wanted to try after this meeting Because
very Amazing And I think bu
byo and This is made
byo of course there are another help
development I think gonz help to build I
don't have but I Think and the page can
be Used To monitor mem
uss appc so Memory use is the common
cause of B Production application so
collecting and observing matrix around
Memory usage is very important there are
several Tools in nojs ecosystem that
Give visibility to Memory management but
clem is Great for basic applications
that want to see how they behav On A
High load of
work and there Is another Uh if you have
High Memory consumption more Complex
scenario you May need to use more Tools
like clinic.js and This is an Open
source Uh nojs project Which provided a
Suite of tools for observing Memory
allocation and It's very very very
complete ok I talk about lot of to and
this topic is very
comp and very interesting so I want to be a
special recommendation if you want to
see more details and information about
this topic Uh you can read a super
comprehensive article that One of the
speakers here at event gonzaga wrote
about it the importance of measuring
Memory applications in nojs really is an
Amazing Amazing Uh
article Okay and If I Work In A huge
Company with billions of things happen
at the same time And I need to have a
100% of control and can see All the
things happen in the right moment Ok if
you need this Uh your operation is very
critical and you need to monitor it
constantly use an
apm tool like neur dat dog or solid this
One That I show you Uh This is a no sour
to is a very very comp to but ok I will
show How
to solve the problems with the most
Amazing
Tools in Production actually but If
after I show
you of all these to you prefer to do
something
yourself Because this is not the best
scenario for
you I will suggest you Amazing video by
erend for creating performance monitor
using js decorators It's very very very
cool Uh tutorial and even if you don't
plan to create your own performance
testing Tools watch it anyway this
tutorial is really really
Amazing okay
So just to make tips for you I want to
indicate two Amazing
articles questions to learn Chrome
developer to there are a moderate Level
and there are Advance Level and before I
read this article Uh I was some That I
know chome developer cough and when I
Start to write the questions I Say okay
I don't have anything about
developer It's very very very good to
study really is Amazing Amazing Uh
article and the Second indication is for
frers please do this course learn carb
vs for Google It's free is in English
and this Will help you a lot to
understand the most important things
about performance in frontend really is
Amazing Amazing course OK
um So Thank you so much for having me
Thank you
foray atten and Me And if you have some
questions You Can Send Me message in
linkedin or in Twitter I don't know and
you can write in English or in Spanish I
will understand both And I will share
this content in I don't know Maybe Half
an Hour so Thank you so much Very Happy
to be here and Thank you so much
Again a
moment Jessica Thank you very
[Applause]
much
Thank you so much
Goodbye, thank you very much for
wait a while I had to dismount
the microphone so that the
message to them and no. Imagine no.
receive such beautiful feedback from
You guys came out spectacular. The talk and
One thing I really like is seeing how
other content creators like another
uh tool maintainers and
Open source libraries found
here also how speakers inspire
other people to learn to create and
share that
knowledge I would like many
of you also be aware of
other conferences that are happening
in Latin America in the world and send
proposals send talk proposals
the best way to learn is Us
also teaching and sharing what
were able to attend Juan's talk
Yesterday Caicedo dressed like a pineapple and
taught us how to animate scrolling with
react the same he said when I want
learn something what I do is prepare
a talk on that topic to force me
to learn that topic because when it comes to
share obviously we need
prepare it super well then
while the next speaker prepares
Tell us how the day goes
Today I see that it is already behind
starting to
fill That's very good then today
we will have several talks later
we are going to start having panels we are going to
have experts here sharing their
backend frontend knowledge let's
see the status of all the
local technology ecosystem here in
Colombia we possibly have a
little surprise out there tucked between the
agenda later we will see it we will
have lunch breaks huh
depending on the weather let's wait and see
how are we doing with the weather today we are going to
take the group photo So I hope not
rain those who brought knife and
fork they cross it and put it outside to
that scared away the clouds for those who did not
They understood the reference, my grandmother.
I did that so it wouldn't rain that's it
very traditional but good if everyone comes out
well and if there is no bad weather outside to the
lunch time we're going out
take the group photo or if it's not our turn
Find a place in the treasure and we
we take the treasure the mall and
we took the photo Now let's go with
the next speaker and an anecdote
Personally, I remember that a few years ago
about five years ago this person
next speaker asked me
javascript stuff and I Well I
advised And this and that now
It's my turn to ask him things
javascript because I really don't have it
idea and he became an expert in the
topic I'm going to give you the introduction
local Colombian talent to Juan José
grove where he is going to tell us and I won't
I know if this is possible or not
javascript can be as fast as
be more of a round of applause for Juan
[Applause]
José
it works for me
listening What fear that is a thousand people
I'm sorry with sorry [ __ ]
scare Well first thing is Thank you very much
for the opportunity to have me here
it's my first
jsconf and it is sadly the last one eh
But hey, it's a fortune to come like
speaker it is a dream it is a dream to be
in this event and on top of that being a speaker is
amazing many
thank you the other the other of what I want
speak is part of this gratitude is
that I really am a son of the
communities, what I have learned has
was thanks to medellin
j I vote for her
I really remember that I received a scholarship for
notc
Colombia and since then I have been a c member
Note then to me a lecture
a community changed my life and I
I want to thank you for that, I mean really.
I feel gratitude and I'm shaking a
a lot also because I'm [ __ ]
scare butier spoke that
I wanted to see more Colombians in the
story and well I feel the truth very
proud
of being
[Music]
Colombian
would love more more more Colombians in in
open source for example what it did
sneider yesterday seemed beautiful to me
it seemed incredible incredible then
invitation mode if you have questions or
something they want to be in the world of the Open
source
Well, it's open to me, no one
denied information then at least
I can do it if anyone needs or
I don't know something ask me ask me why
in order to have more presence
Colombians in open source Where
can I put
this
excellent and also a round of applause please
for team organization that accommodate
1000 people in a benu is not a
job
it's a job
easy good I really came to talk
of javascript and how can it be
I'm not as efficient as I am anymore
lying
spoiler people
spanish
Linux Linux New Linux here we Speak
right to Speak in Spanish Because All
the documentations about all this stuff
is in English which is a shame so I'm to
you know Speak Spanish Because you have
All the information over
there it is that's me
I think they call me well I call myself
tree but my last name is grove that
It's my Instagram and Twitter handle
when they give me very nice things they say Wow what
Man so cute they take a photo of me and
tagan on instagram or or on Twitter but
When I'm ugly, no, please. Ah, I am.
Note I do Note I do contributor
Note releases I break their environments
of production with
Rafa Ah I contribute to B8 B8 is the engine
Java Script developed by Google
Chrome other contributors and partially
I
I have also contributed to Live es la
bookstore that is responsible for providing The ev
Loop a Note and well I have another life No
my personal life that is much more
boring and I don't plan to talk about
she, time is of the essence, we don't have much
little time So we have to
define an agenda an agenda certain
let's talk about language books
of c+ compilers more of javascript of
biology
economy
neuroscience and quantum mechanics but
Since time is short, let's talk
Nietzsche economics and quantum mechanics
ready then I've been doing great lately
busy with definitions
etymological So let's define the
text and excuse me for reading then text
comes from the Latin textus and means
woven link hence the texts
present many related elements
each other Oops sorry
Ah the words in a linear way but
sometimes forming a framework in which it is
easy to get lost that is very important that
it is a lattice this is a fabric this
It is literally RAM memory that is
hand woven with threads exactly as
a text that is when we write Ah
well and this is the RAM memory of the Apollo
11 super important So when
we write software
we are writing texts too and
then when we started talking our
code not as a set of instructions
but as text they begin to grow or
become other things like antipatterns
good practices bad practices that is
code is not just code
code can be literature too if
HE
wants one of my favorite authors
Jorge Luis Borges calls, well I tell him
borito because I love him very much and he
says something about the books of the various
instruments of man the most amazing
It is without a doubt the book the others are
extensions of your body the microscope
the telescope are extensions of your
view the telephone is extension of the voice
then we have the plow and the sword
extensions of his arm but the book is
otherwise the book is an extension of
memory and imagination
definition we are rigorous when
we write software we write text that
the resolution can be saved in books
of problems through code is a
creative exercise in my opinion is a
imagination exercise when I have
to solve a programming problem
I have to be creative I have to
have imagination and basically
definition I am extending when
I write code I extend my memory and my
imagination according to Don Borges memory
It's because we're documenting all of this.
no then we can see in ghub a
a lot of for example gab a lot of
ah Records we are Ah well Yes
we are extending memory because
we store all that code okay Ah
It turns out that in the past people
He communicated through symbols, let's think
for example in the Egyptians who had
a symbol for the sun a symbol for
a cup and systematically we can
have infinite symbols but the brain
It's finite And that's a problem because
so how do we communicate how
we represent all through
little drawings it's almost impossible ah
Oops I'm going to see my
grades
yes it is very similar to the
binary representation that is, with
segments of zeros and ones we can
represent almost everything but that is a
problem because it is that programming in
binary is it's horrible or nobody
no one wants to do that then later
we evolve just like language
then systems begin to appear
syllabics And we began to converse better
we can understand each other and the same thing happens with
programming we began to have
assembler that Ugh although it is a lot
better than reading ones and zeros Well, neither
I think it's the best way to write
code and what happens with this, what is it?
to be able to write this first it takes you
a lot of time doing anything
Ah second just like writing on
In the past it was reserved for very large groups.
small academic types ah
people with a lot of money who had time
to do research but with the
standardization of the
computing we decide how do you know what
we are going to program the computers in
english thank you Grace hopper I love you
then everything becomes easier because
then we started to have a
clearer conversation with
computers we no longer talk about
assembler not even in binary but
We have a language that unites us, which is
English and we can talk more
easily with computers and that
It seems fantastic because it happens
Exactly the same with language
natural when we agree that we are going to
speak the same language all
explodes but then it starts to appear
also abstract language when I
I can have general ideas ideas
abstract Well it turns out that with the
programming languages ​​the same thing happens
and this seems brutal to me, that is, having a
generalized compression algorithm
It is an algorithm that works for
compress images and it's over is not a
algorithm that compresses whatever and that
can be achieved is with languages
programming not with sequences of one or
it would take a long time to abstract is is is
a serious problem So me with code
I can abstract
behaviors
features a lot of things the same
that natural language code us
allows you to create ideas and ideas through
extractions and that seems to me it seems to me
beautiful is going to
cry Well but this Man Why not
is talking about history the language
I don't know what this Man
manque returning to the symbology this is
a little toy because we can assume that it is
a little bear Maybe a stuffed animal gives us the
idea of ​​what it is
nice light let's call it
javascript that is nice to prototype
let him do things
But we have another
symbol that I don't know what it represents
I plan to say it but let's call them
the rest
But for some reason we are going to call them
The rest is more robust
I eat heavier I don't know enough
dangerous and what I want to talk about is
What's happening
when when
We put it together. So what can come out of it?
this I don't know I don't know let's see let's see
that
Come on, I'm going to talk about B8, right, because now
We already got serious and I'm going to talk about
what I came to talk about
It really turns out that all
programming languages ​​need a
specification
that is, programming languages
obey grammatical syntactic rules
just like spanish then for me
there is not much distinction between the Real
Academy of the Spanish language and t9 that
takes care of specifying javascript OR
whether I write a word wrong in
javascript and I have bad syntax that's not it
is javascript valid as if in
Spanish I try to invent a word
well that's not spanish and no one is going to tell me
understand I usually speak in dialects
with myself So I'm going to make a
very small demo
tiny
of the
stop then Is the font size ok?
I'll make it smaller, that's fine.
but this is not Oops I am
doing is this So we have a a
javascript file called
js and it is simply a conditional
It's written wrong. Yes, everything is fine.
So we know it's misspelled.
why Because the tc train already told us
that an If no is not written like that in
javascript unif no is not written like that in
javascript then what I'm going to do
do is go to this function of B8 This is
the source code of B8 the engine that is
couple calls If statement and what it will
doing this function is validating that my
javascript syntax if it is really the
that was specified no then I have a
token If a right parenthesis a
expression and a right parenthesis and such
once an Else statement that's what I
I want to see what happens Okay then I'll do it
I have my debugger here
ready here I am deando B8 and I put the
breakpoint in that even If function
statements
u Okay then how can you see my Deer
is where it should be okay and I am
starting to consume the tokens token
lation parenthesis then the parenthesis AND
If you can see here is a function that
called spect I'm basically
waiting for that then I'm going to enter
inside that function and let's see what
It happens I don't enter here I have another Macro that I
He says like Oops if this is not what it seems
like the next toen is not the one
token that I am waiting for I am going to
report unexpected token true
So let's look and see that the
function passes Okay then I'll give it
continue and here I have the parser
said unexpected
token stop That is the parser and that is
responsible for validating that javascript
javascript code that we are
sending then the Spec
okay but it is super complex and has another
very important unit for this talk and
and for my heart also called
the compiler what is going to do
compiler is grabbing my javascript code
and convert it into an assembler or that
It's crazy how javascript ends
being an assembler for that too
I have a tiny one
demoy again see
Here I have this javascript function that
called rap and what rap does is
calculate the parity of a number if
a number is even so it's going to tell me and
If it's not, that's okay, but I have one.
syntax there as kind of weird like Oops that one
that percentage symbol what was called
native syntax those are B8 helpers
to debug the behavior of B8
This is only for development, not
never use in
production and is more or
less self explaining worth what me
He says this is how to prepare this function for me
optimize the rap function I call it and
then he tells me then I tell him how best
on the next call So what
I hope that in the second call
this function becomes
assembler and for that I also had
Here's a little myth that I'm going to use
B8 I am going to send you the allow flag
native
syntax to be able to allow that syntax
of percentage
prepare, I'm going to send you the trace flag
optimization that what it will give me is a
lock of when the function is optimized and
this FL called trace Turbo already
Let's see what I'm putting it for
the microphone too far away Okay then
I have a lock here just as I asked and
look look at this lock so cute begin
compiling method WAP using turbofan
turbofan is the B8 compiler and here
I have the lock that
finished So what does trace do?
What Turbo TR Turbo does is create a
archvillain in some
OK place that represents me My code
in nodes here we can see that it is the
rap function and here we have a graph
of nodes that tells me here I start here
I return something and here I end it is not it is not
nothing the other
world But if I want more details I
I can have something like that I have a graph
much more complex. He writes to me a lot
better how my code works and
Well, returning to these forms of
language I don't know what there is a there is a gentleman
I love what I know but not like that
way that
He calls his name Chomski and it turns out that
Chomski takes natural language and is
able to analyze it and I believe that this
graph looks similar
quite a bit to this other one that is to say the theory
of compilers is strongly linked
to the theory of natural language and that
I am fascinated by the existence of
symbiosis between How we speak and how
we talk to the machines then
To understand this node graph I
what I do is first understand my
javascript code and then guide me with it
graph to look at what is there
passing Okay then I'll go for example
here to this node called speculative
number module if you can see the
graph I do it more
zoom more zoom I quote good good
Well, thank you very much, then yes, I
I start from the top I see this Man who
It tells me parameter One which is the n That is
the first parameter of that function I have
here then I am trying to continue as
I have the connections of this graph here
then this is a constant number
two which is the number two we have
there Ah then I have this one that is
speculative number moduleus the module is
this percentage symbol and what it does
bat to optimize like javascript doesn't
it's a
strongly typed language what it does
bate is to speculate
Ah yes this is a I think this is a
number maybe and if the speculation
fulfills what I optimize and if it doesn't I get out of
all that pipeline and I'll try it later
or mark it as
Ah function that cannot be optimized
so if you see I'm joining the
parameter one n with uh a constant two
a number two a scalar two and the
Ah, I join you with the speculation of
module but then we have another
speculation speculative number equal
which corresponds to the three equals
so I'm concatenating all my
code This is particularly a code
simple Because if we don't get into a
very problem
serious but then then I am
speculating that with the number C then
I'm comparing what that one is
speculation is equal to zero okay then
I make the return and finally finish my
my software well my my code B8 pass your
code through all these phases of
optimization some are responsible for
put types on it he tries to put types on it
others to optimize
recursions but finally a
a schedule that is to represent all
those whole graph in code like that
run that can be
read I remember that I solved a
book of that compiler and I found out that the
order of this is super important because
what the cpu does is like running, reading and
If you have to make a jump, come back or
It goes down and then it has to go up again.
if the inlining the pat is downwards
perfect as a plumb your code
ends up being more efficient after
that we have that this representation well
this has a kind of dictionary that
ends up converting my code
javascript in assembler this is
assembler for my computer
which seems incredible to me, we have one
equivalence relationship between
javascript and assembler I come back here my
presentation and returning again to the
to the history of language we have the
rosette stone where we have here the
binary and the equivalent I don't know in ya
javascript in c+ plus in python whatever
but it works exactly the same is the
same concept is a stone that
gives an equivalence relation between a
text and another then I love that
all these super theoretical people in the
programming languages ​​use
exactly or at least I intuit it
same theory of natural language. That
seems
fascinating then we see that this pair
together they scare me a lot, I mean
The truth is that it seems incredible to me
can make a bear and And that
thing then I can wake up
suspicions like Well, but it's just that you
You are telling me that it is so efficient
as sem ma I don't know if that assembler
that you necessarily showed me more
efficient than most likely no no
I know I don't know because it is assembled
literally the people of de
saw then I'm going to talk about something that
It calls Fast Api calls that only for
node type bers
cl
name so for that I'm going to use no and
in I have here a small
demo I don't know if well first I implemented one
node library called Juan
true and has a function that calls
even then I'm going to send request
this so we don't have to download
more him
package
and I will follow the same logic
prepare function for optimization blah
blah blah This is the bookstore in
javascript implements another function but
is even
binding to a code in c+ more I'll get to you
to show what code does and
What that code does is tell me if the
number is Power or not but if you notice here
I gave it a naming convention that this goes
to be slow because if you notice there is a
Lots of B8 There's nothing here
c+ má really, that is, the c+ má code is
is this is is a super trivial thing Ah
when I run javascript I am not
running only javascript I am
running an engine behind then I
I have runtime not only javascript
but that that engine that structure that
I'm supporting all that javascript and
I have this Fast that what it is going to do is
Call an external c+ library more
here it is called Ju Fast is even that
this is literally c+ ma this is a
c+ helper can be a library
of c+ ma If you want and let's run
that code
oh I am
[Music]
nervous Okay then I'm going to
allow this Man the native syntax
because I need it to know what I know
optimizes and when not but If we return to
here in the slow part I put a
printf to tell me and You know what Me
I'm running this from the slow version
and for the quick version that is more more
I put a lock on it that tells me you know
I'm running the fast version
then I'm going to run
this and it turns out that then when I
I run my javascript Well before
be optimized I run javascript but
after optimization I am
[ __ ] more more then I don't
I end up running javascript otherwise Oh yeah
more So this doesn't look like this
it's more
So it's very curious how you end up
[ __ ] more more and no javascript on
a javascript engine it seems to me
incredible and so I conclude that you
javascript can be as efficient as
your c+ if you are an embed and you have Api in
c+ you can make those bindings using Fast
Api calls and you end up running to c+ more
and not javascript Many
[Applause]
thank you excellent Ave
Mary, what was that whole journey for God?
history philosophy
neuroscience missing quantum metric
The quantum metric was missing and V Why
I told them that I have to ask questions to
He I don't know absolutely anything but
well, thank you very much
Thank you, I will return the flag because
Then they say that one here takes the
things and without anything Thank you very much
thank you all another applause for Juan
by
[Applause]
Please, you already saw in a conf no.
another conference that also many of
here we organize the last one We did it in
In 2019 we had everything ready for
sponsors
design of everything and I don't know what happened in it
2020 but we had to Cancel
Unfortunately but
well, as he said, he won a scholarship
we did some workshops for
teach How to contribute to the project
very simple nojs were assigned to the
assistants a book or a feature that
had to be implemented in the tests
nojs nothing that requires semmo todo
this science behind it And I think that
That was where he had his first meal and
He went crazy and see where he is
wonderful So I also invite you to
you take advantage of it
look for it all who want
contribute to the nodu project to another
project he already has a great journey
in everything that is a contribution of Open
source And it can really help you
That's pretty much what this conference is for.
that's what this community is for
among all of us he also pushed us
let's give and continue putting the name of
Colombia and
Latin America on the map so that others
please keep us in
says an expert on issues of
meteorology one of my best friends
who is hidden there sent me a
message and told me that there are no clouds in
the Horizon so suddenly it doesn't rain
Let's hope that the radars of the Cata
are correct and things go very well for us
the now later and to continue
with local talent although I already retired
the flag But we have another talent
local I want to welcome you to
Maris Botero Maris Botero is going to come to us
to talk about generative art and
computational creativity with javascript
please give a very loud applause for
Maris bter thank you
hello
hello how are you well it's more intimidating
what seems to stop here
eh Thank you very much to Juan for that
talk I loved it
Hey well, today I want to talk to you
little bit of art and the presentation itself
It is made in javascript, I am not going to tell you
explain all the little images but there
They are eh I introduce myself here in front of
you are only a human being who
He really likes to paint, he likes it
nature and good And firmly believes that
with a computer and can be created as
a world of colors then Today
I come to read a little bit of
that's generative art, art
generative when we talk about this type
of art Unlike other aspects
where the artist creates a work here
What the artist does is create a whole
system system and this system from the
The theory of systems is a
set of elements that work between
Yes, for example, we can have a system
of natural language which is much of what
which is used today in Intelligence
artificial that are systems that eh
They feed on our own language and
wonderful things or a system are created
uh of algorithms a set of
instructions for creating a work of
art so that's what this is about
talk about How we can use
javascript How can we create those
systems and create works of art
eh the origins of art and art
generative dating back to Prehistory
because ancient cultures used
different geometries and symmetries to
create uh artistic forms and express a
those cultures a little bit but it was more or
except in the 19th century when this
art trend began to gain strength
there are many references to art
generative artists use these
people as inspiration But I like it
much to mention Vera mornier who is
She was a Hungarian artist, a woman, and she was
of the pioneers who came up with
combine computing with art and
Today many artists use it
inspiration they try to replicate their works
to be able to learn the art from this
generative uses several techniques
They automate an entire system and
random elements to generate works
completely
different there are different inspirations
eh for this type of art we have the
nature, for example, I love it
look at the leaves of the trees see how
move and try to replicate that huh And
There are fractals, for example
snowflakes that seem incredible to me
Because all snowflakes have
a very similar shape but they are
different from each other Then this
mathematics and This universal language
allows you to paint those colorful canvases and
Well, thanks to javascript we
we can create incredible things this is a
This is an area that welcomes everyone.
type of people receive artists
programming engineers and programmers
receives journalists from data architects
and it is basically a laboratory
experimentation and creativity
to paint with many colors I am going to
tell a story
uh once upon a time there was a little one
programmer called
Pixel Pixel lived in a digital world and
he dreamed of painting the world with colors
But I did not know how
Pixel was very worried because he
I wanted to fill the world with a lot of
things and show your inner world but
I didn't know how to bring it to reality
then in his digital world he found
a path and that path led him to a
Magic kingdom and that kingdom
it was called javascript Pixel the first
he felt he was overwhelmed
eh but he also realized that he had
a lot of possibilities and found
four magical guardian guardians who
They gave Pixel a lot of powers
the first Guardian was called p5js PF js
He was adorable and very benevolent towards Pixel
that was just catching on
pif js taught Pixel to paint the
world with colorful stars and
many flowers after he met 3js
3js taught you how to create structures in
third dimension and created suns suns
giants who danced with each other after
I met the third Guardian paper js a
guardian of lines and shapes and
taught Pixel to create colored lines
to create the structure of rivers and
wavy shapes of mountains
finally the fourth Guardian
Djs The data alchemist taught him
Pixel to transform a million data
and shapes in images
each of these amazing
guardians taught Pixel and gave him
powers and Pixel discovered
that with a little imagination with a
code with a language
Amazing programming like javascrip
could paint her world and turn her into
a work
teacher but wait wait let's do a
in pixel Pixel Pixel Ah Pixel is you
Pixel you are that you are that little one
programmer and you can paint the world
of
colors
so
[Applause]
Well then here what was for you
telling this little story of me
Little friend Pixel is one of the bookstores with
the ones that I get to play in my time
basically this talk is about
of things that I do only because I
I have fun without any pretension and eh Son
libraries that I like pif js It is one
super easy to use tool eh
can build amazing things and
eh you can learn in a very very way
simple and replicate all these systems
mathematicians who were telling them what
What we try to do with these
images is trying to capture that world
those those those things that we see those
leaves that inspiration that we have from the
nature for example And try to
carry the code with those systems that
I told them that information structure
and to be able to paint it on the Canvas eh DJs
It is a tool that is used
a lot in the entire generation of
video game images can be
render very well in real time and eh
paper js if you like it
geometry like me and vectors is It
a very powerful tool too
to make this type of images when
we need a detail eh and precision
geometric and finally eh d3js It is a
tool that enhances everything
the use of data we may
create works
hey great, that is, just spend a
graphic
eh of a p of a pie or a graph of
bars to create works totally
different with this data set to
one of the things I like most about
javascript is to make things move
so hey when I started programming
I am also a daughter of the communities
when I was able to move something on the web
like in the Canvas I fell in love with
javascript javascript changed my
life and for me it is colors it is shapes it is
lines So that's like a little bit
of what I wanted to show them then
For me these libraries allow me
do that and play
basically Well then here I am going to
show uh some examples This work is
calls
bifurcation And as it was
saying So on this art topic
generative, what we are trying to do is take
those mathematical elements those things
that we see those those structures
geometrics is to try to take it to
code and what we have here is this work
which is called a converted Eh fork
Well, to code with bif js a system
a fork is a system eh that
It was stable and there comes a time when
there is an alteration and it changes completely
then it came to a question of balance
It came balanced and arrives completely
and it becomes a chaotic system
So if it has happened to them
ever a fork here
We also have another system that
uses a lot of lines and curved shapes
where we use a few elements
random to create This this this
complex behind this complex There is
a bunch of mathematical formulas is not
so difficult but what we are looking for is
try to systematize all those
instructions Add items
random and be able to build a work
completely
new these particular works have
a characteristic Y is that they are
interactive in new aspects
of generative art it is sought that each
viewer has a unique experience and
these in particular feed on
millions and millions of data then
we can see exhibitions where you can
interact with these works power
generate movement and enrich
all these systems with
data here we have a fractal system i
I have a personal obsession with
fractals is that I don't know how
explain to them but I see the world as if
it was a mathematical equation I everything
I lead as well as numbers and patterns of
information then the fractals to
They are very magical to me and here we are seeing
a symmetrical rectal eh we are
using recursion and also what
we generate is a movement from
of the mouse and then we vary the
angle to see that
figure Well I'm going to show you
finally the perlin noise that
also used in generative art to
trigger
animations very similar to the
nature So we are inspired like
in the fire in the air in the
movement of currents to power
generate this type of images and
build art
eh And well that's what my talk was about
I wanted to show them that with javascript
we can paint the world with colors
we can do amazing things we can
use these libraries to make art
generative There are a lot of tools
but for me on a personal level, well
jait is the tool that allows me
do it day by day and it makes me very happy and
Generative art for me is like
life like one needs those
random elements but also one
you need to have a path
that confidence of going one way but
also being able to release that balance
balance But also that letting go
things and that they happen as they should and that
This is what generative art allows
for me to be surprised because sometimes I
I generate random elements and say how
Wow that's so cool and other times take
control and suddenly show what I
I wanted to convey how the movement of
the leaves or surprise me with the
fractals of nature then for
It's like that dance between letting go and flowing
but also control certain patterns
and that was all they had
I wanted to show a lot
[Applause]
thank you mar Thank you very much for your
talk and your beautiful story I hope
many of you will also be inspired to
create with
javascript we have more char than
creativity that is encouraged in all
artists who are working with Este
language so they can share
what you do jsc Colombia is not
only Colombia this is a celebration of
all of Latin America JC Colombia has
inspired other communities to others
conferences also to start creating and
to start sharing then before
prepare the next speaker for me
I would like you to
They will help without shame and they will do
representation of their countries Who is from
Argentina but there is no one from
Argentina yesterday I saw at least a couple
Well I know that here I am going to have noise
chile that we have people from chile there are
people from
Paraguay there is no
Paraguay
Brazil
eh there are people from
Peru, let's go
well I know there are people here from Bolivia
hey Lupe how good very
good
Ecuador Ecuador wonderful how good
we have people here from
Venezuela that Venezuela What beauty
Let's see who else from the south I'm missing someone
from the guyanas Who is not but it is we are
in the south we go
uploading Uruguay who from Uruguay is there
people from Uruguay do not
Panama that for some of Panama
Republic
Dominican Coast
Rica Puerto Rico not good What am I missing
Guatemala
Honduras that
Salvador, there are more people here who
more from Central America
Colombia is missing who
Colombia Well there is a great
Latin American representation here for
our next speaker I want
all of Mexico give him support
who of
Mexico what happens Mexico So
From Mexico we have Martín Manriquez
He is a Facebook community leader
developer circles of Mexico City and we
is going to talk about exploring creativity
with javascript Introduction to creative
coding let's give a round of applause to Martín
manriquez please what's up how are you
I hope you are feeling very well and
well that's my name but most of me
known as Hello, I'm malba Normally
I spend my time sharing memes and making
internet jokes about technology and
well today we are going to talk about how
make technology with art combine it with
music and Machine learning then I
I really like writing code and
throw code I am this friend here
worked with some of these companies
and well today we are going to do Live
coding hard pig without respect and for
those who want to get involved and include themselves
in this type of topics These are three
channels that I highly recommend Art
and Technology from Coach trin that has
a specialized course in creativity and
code and specifically the ts talks of
creative coding those two are very good
in case they leave the talk before
Let's start and well I like it
divide it like it's a game
So we're going to divide it into four.
phases art technology art more
technology And where to start and well
Starting with the part of art that
specifically it is art and this is where
we have to start thinking about the
history of art when we
we return to the history of art we have
had different different streams
types of styles different materials and
here comes the interesting part though
we would think that technology was coming
separated from art we have seen that the
art has evolved along with
technology then in this part here
we will see precisely that the materials
They evolved at the same time as the
art was evolving, whether new
new pigments new textures
materials until reaching chems la
culmination of art and they are not going to give it to me
letting lie is art when we
we see chams because we say it's cinema and
well, this has come precisely to the
combination with a part that is the
generative part of code in which
we can make interactions
immersive and today I am going to show you how
we can do an interactive immersion
with facial recognition and generation
of music and well, as I mentioned,
technology has been advancing together with
art from what the media were
analog to digital media
today And well, we already saw that art
technology has evolved
evolved side How has the
part of art plus technology
which we coincidentally know as artch and
well in this part here we will see that
there are different types of implementations
either one completely digital and another that
It is in this case analogue that is when
we have microcircuits we have
arduinos and we use servomotors to
generate investment in this case already physical
and well there are different types of
technologies that we can use when
we work with analog technologies
we can work with arduino or with
raspberry pie when we work with
digital technologies we can work
with the Chrome engine we can work
with pfi processing MLS or Flow tensor and
Well here comes the interesting part.
part of starting to write code for
see how good we are and if there are
accidents because this is where the
Accidents 'cause this is where we go
start making live code and I
I really like to start with where
start we have to see what it is
what is going to call us
attention we normally believe that as
developers, engineers, we are not
creative But the reality is that we are
very creative to throw code and
solve problems when we
we have to arrive with our project
manager after a week why not
we did nothing we have to be creative
to invent something no and when we
we are faced with an algorithm that does not
We know how to solve we have to be
creative again then I'm going to
give me some tips to get started
something that I quite like is taking as
reference works of art that I like
pretty Then let's start
do something like that and the first thing
What I'm going to do is open the folder
with eh correct and Well here I already put a
small Canvas to start shooting
code and what would follow in this case
would be to develop what would be my
Canvas here I have a pretty Canvas
simple I only have the size I have the
colors that I will be using for
generate what would be my stone painting
and I will be working a size for
the paintings if we realize in the
Pat's work we have paintings
of different sizes So how
we're going to be doing this whole part
from here in this case what I'm going to start
to do is a function to start
generate squares in an ordinary way and know
What position should I put them in?
adding I add the coordinates in the
internal part I have to define the
coordinates in x and y because we
In this case we have a matrix in which
part of the for we are going to iterate what
would be the different paintings and in the
internal part I will iterate through
of the matrix that we have so that
we can print these pictures
once we have that Ford we are going to
add a constant to define
We are going to send to each of the paintings
to call frame by frame and once
I already know that it is in position x and that
It's going to be in position and we're going to irl
distributing So let's add
a random variable to go
randomly distributing what
would be our different paintings and in
the internal part I am going to make a splice
to add them but there is something
important this is only in
horizontally we also need to work
vertically an apology if I speak too much
fast it seems like I'm high but it's
my way of being Oh yes I'll upload the code now
Yes I saw someone doing like this
I said Oh I think it's a battle of
Beatbox right now we are going to release daap ea ea
The ugly doll and if she doesn't know, it's better
Don't even see Hey well here is the function in
and to work What would be vertical and
horizontally and on the inside I go
to do a split in x to add
what the different squares would be
here I'm going to add what would be the
table we are going to divide each of the
paintings to cut them out
adding and Here we are going to add what
would be the boxes in x the boxes in y
and distribute them through what
it would be our space we are adding
fast fast fast
Fast
AB there perfect Yes if I don't do more
small the font like tiny type or
bigger they tell me and well here now
we are like distributing the part of the
split in X in and add what would be
the Square we print them in squar Ah no
I explained the code I'm sorry I felt
like in a technical interview But
well eh we have to generate what
they would be eh the squares create them and go
adding inside the Canvas then I go
to do a reset so that in this case
every time I need a new painting
a new generation we can go
then adding here what I'm going to
do is you know what the squares I'm going to do
clean let's start from scratch and
let's add the draw function to
be able to draw it on the inside
we are going to add the squares of
randomly and in the internal part
I'm going to tell him you know what when it starts
the pad we are going to add them in a way
this case eh new eh totally in
white we add the squares in y x Wi e
In the internal part we add the color
let's add the style part
fill stroke background and it would only make us
In this case, a set needs to be added
interval for it to be
automatically updating then
here we already have the cre Square we have the
create context and add what would be
the Time out set so that it is
adding Well in this case every certain
time and let's try it here in
production Okay my production
it failed let's go here it was demo 2 and here
our figure is and is working
of piet as you see we were able to do it one
simple way in quotes Only
we need to know how to work with matrices
and here the idea is quite interesting
Because if we can learn to work
with matrices through a game like
do this when we get to a
Pinterest-type technical interview and we
ask Hey we need that in the feed
Pinterest in this case you distribute to
through pagination certain amount of
images as we will have it in the sti
official only that related to a
product so that it can be connected to a
e-commerce in those types of cases, well
we saw an idea of ​​how we can
distribute the different elements
inside a matrix that would be ours
Canvas if we had a fit in this case
like it could be on Instagram eh De
soon Twitter or a fit like the one from
Pinterest to distribute different
elements we will already have an idea of ​​how
work on it and that is something quite a bit
interesting now another way
we have to be able to work
this is Search for references For example
If we saw this reference of
come Frank we see that we have this
image that moves when we
we are moving our mouse but how
We can do it and here it comes again
another of the demos that I brought you that day
Today in this case we are going to start
generate a pupil the pupil and the eye and
In the internal part we are going to start
detect what would be the position of
our Mouse through our Canvas
What would be our browser then?
this part here Oh let's hit it here
let's start adding what it would be
our element eh we are going to send it to
call by Class name that would be ours
pupil we are going to send it to be added
within an arrangement to be able to
work if we have several elements
similar and within an input we are going to
add what the movement would be
mouse on x and mouse movement
And then we add the movement
of the mouse on and we already added the
mouse movement in x we ​​need
generate an input the input is going to be the
mouse position when we
let's move and in this case it will be
the beginning of X which would be our Mouse
in the initial position of the Canvas and
our Mouse in the final position where
we have moved it within the
Canvas after this we are going to add the
position in y since we have equal two
dimensions our Canvas is in
vertically and horizontally and well let's
define an output this output will be
defined by the position at x where
we are moving and
position in and where we also
we are moving and in this part here
Well, we are going to add the range of
output of what would be the data that
we register we add the handler
to detect what would be the
movement of the pupil and we add the
What would be the current positions?
we fraction so we can divide it
through which would be the position of
our pupil and be able to distribute it now
we only add the position of each
pupil if we have several pupils
we add a resize handler to go
adding or moving what would be the
pupil position that is going to be a
circular element and finally we add
an ad event handler to go in this case
detecting the position in which
we are finding ourselves if we
let's go here again let's go to our
demo number one I think let's see
that the pupil works and if it does
We compare with the example of Venan Frank
we are doing something similar we are
using the characteristics of
browser to develop a handler and go
following or tracking the position of
our Mouse if we realize This
battery works both vertically and
horizontal in the case of venan Frank
It only works horizontally
then we would only use x and there is
several things we can continue doing
whether for example we
let's start combining music and we have
to define, for example, what would be the
bit we're going to be on
working let it be something bigger
because I'm half blind and well
we would have to define which one goes
to be the time with which we are going to be
working and the duration of the
different loops with which we are going to
be Well in this case interacting
the chords and the melody that we are going to
be integrating and finally what
it would be the musical composition Podemos
add more than one and when
we Ah let's play this would sound
something
[Music]
like that but like that Uh what happens when we
we combine
This is what happens when we
we combine this with what we saw
previously javascript What if still
like we play it a little more
and we add Machine learning and that is where
very interesting things come
What can we do with all the
part of generative art right now
we start we are seeing some of this
which is like very simple, very simple and
something very cool about generative art is that
right now all countries are like in
the same level as when Mexico
competed with the United States on the issue
Well, from the movies in the during the
golden era of Mexican cinema
quality of the movies was very similar
Unfortunately Mexico did not follow
developing the industry then
both in the augmented reality part
in the virtual reality part in the
part of generative code and art to
through technology many countries
They are just making inroads then.
So it's a good time to
be there develop libraries support
in the Open source part because
It is precisely a very rich field and
opportunities and something that was
talking yesterday with a friend is that in
the case of javascript with Machine
learning is a very fruitful place
because all the bookstores that already
they exist in python they do not exist in
javascript we only have kera AND
we have Flow sensor we have MLS and for
there suddenly p5 but not really
We have as many bookstores as
exist within python So it is a
very fruitful place If we want to do
our first contributions and
we want to start experimenting with it
Machine learning and this is where it comes
like all the interesting part Through
from webgl development we can
generate three-dimensional models and
analyze models Well, in this case
3D physics through our
browsers and within parties
interesting thing that we also have is that
we have web embly that allows us to do
Well, generative art through Machine
learning and this is where it comes like all
the interesting part here I'm going to
show a small demo that I bring
In this case it is for the face part
when we are here and I hit it
generate and detect what would be
facial recognition here is the face
and when I make gestures I go
moving his hands he generates
music
Hello there then we can go
making interactions of this type
where we are combining not only the
that we have seen for example of Canvas
basic where we generate a ball Y of
soon We have a square there Or change
the colors but we can add in
in this case machine learning models
train them combine them with art
generative and also add them with
music So we are already doing
things that call us
attention and be quite interesting
regarding companies that suddenly
they want to make interactions for
users or suddenly for us to
be playing with something that we
we would consider a hobby like music
or the paint and here it comes like something
also very interesting and very nice
this type of projects in publishing
especially digital you will find that
There are many very good projects where
we are going to suddenly have in the
Trump elections that when he wins a
state Trump is there the state and leaves
the little flag there of the democrats or yes
biden wins, explodes the flag of the
republicans So in that kind of
cases we see that the interactions give
a Plus to the user experience
So it is something very interesting that
although it seems like it's just a game
already putting it into practice it has Well
in this case quite an interaction
cool in which we give it as another Plus
to the user experience Although
quite complicated and good eh
essence that will be all I am going to add
here quite a few references to books and
little things like that and something that
I wanted to comment is that I am part of
a little group that we call ourselves those of
talkers And we have a scholarship program
Currently, we are giving away scholarships.
because we know that many do not have
access to the courses or bootcamps part
and we are giving away 10 scholarships for
domestic for them to study creative
coding so if you want to give yourself a
back there we will be organizing the
dynamics both cares Arelis and Eric
Almaraz have scholarships so
dynamics are quite simple Suddenly
is to solve an algorithm or Share by
There is the answer. I solve something that
find and these scholarships are totally
free are 100% so that you
they can take them
okay so thank you very much excellent talk
I hope you are inspired to do everything
this type of art a recommendation
when you get home
We watch the videos
YouTube has an option where you can do it
see 1.7
a75 to point5 so that you already feel like
at speed at normal speed
because it was about 1.5 meters away, that's a
very good sign that the coffee that
we are giving out
It's powerful powerful very good Let's go
leave earlier to break eh I don't know
Let's tell me if it is ready or
no but the tables are not there yet
ready we're going to have a little bit of
patience let's hope everything is
organized they line up so that
you can have the break of the
tomorrow this break is sponsored by the
laboratory laboratory equipment
Thank you very much for sponsoring the
break this
tomorrow I ask you the favor of
they cleared the entire auditorium for me
everyone needs all of these
empty chairs we have to make a couple
little things here for the next block
enjoy the break I recommend that
have a coffee, not much because there are still
just as bad well accelerate well well
and enjoy the break that it sponsors
many laboratories
thank you
[Music]
oh
and
[Music]
k
oh
[Music]
and
g
oh
[Music]
I have
oh
[Music]
and
oh
[Music]
Q
[Laughs]
[Music]
and
Oh
[Music]
[Laughs]
bu
[Music]
oh
and
[Music]
[Music]
oh
Oh
[Music]
oh
k
[Laughs]
[Music]
oh
Oh
[Music]
ye
[Laughs]
[Music]
Hey
Oh
[Music]
he
oh
[Music]
and
h
[Music]
oh
to
Oh
oh
[Music]
g
Oh
[Music]
oh
Oh
[Music]
I have
[Laughs]
Oh
[Music]
oh
Hey
[Music]
oh
Oh
[Laughs]
[Music]
oh
Oh
non-profit organization that is
working to encourage women
integrate into everything that is this world of
technology through education
I invite you to visit the stand
of them outside is quite a project
nice and if any of you want
also start a career in
technology strengthen your knowledge
I'm sure which laboratory is going to be a
great Ally for you Now let's go
to continue with the JC Colombia in this
day two the last day of the event
we have a surprise guest
let's not reveal it yet I'm going to make one
small production eh this guest is
one of the entrepreneurs
Latin Americans more
important projects contribute
Open source technologies we have come from
using
since almost the origins of the web in
javascript And now I know that many
They use many of the technologies that
He and the company behind him have
created creator of
nexts and ceo of the verel company we have
to William
r
good Guillermo, thank you very much for
join us today we couldn't have it here
Guillermo is obviously a
quite busy person but
We convinced and we have it here a while ago
time we had a similar problem
and he promised us that he would change
completely developed in Java
I hope that Guillermo will start to tell us
publishing projects in java ever not
Guillermo lies So let's
ask Guillermo some questions about
the current state of the ecosystem in
javascript Guillermo is one of the
most important people as I told you
entrepreneurship in Latin America and
also in the entire web ecosystem in
javascript then Guillermo from your
perspective What are those trends
most exciting uals in javascript AND
How do you think that those of us who are here?
developers can work
to start incorporating these
technologies and
trends well first of all I
they listen
good
very good very good very good good
First of all, well, many
thank you for having me here, a big hug to
the entire organizational team Julián
Adrián Juan Pablo buriticá Eh I would have
Loved to be in person but
It's true that I also love being in
a giant screen I feel like
I'm in a science fiction movie
So with the topics we are going to talk about
today from artificial intelligence comes
perfect
e First of all I also loved them
comment that I am very excited about
the future of the community I know that this
it is the last one
eh Colombia But there are going to be many
more events in the future eh eh follow us
inviting us to continue spreading the la
javascript typescript community
nextjs all over the world So I am
very excited about the future look at them
I tell something very important and very
personal about javascript javascript
defined my entire career I learned
javascript when everyone told me
that javascript wasn't going anywhere
I always remember even my parents
my old man who liked the subject of reading
About the programming he told me I don't know if
javascript is going to be a language
It is important that you learn Java
it is convenient to learn seb ma like just
Julián said, I'm not going to learn Java.
what excites me most about javascript
is that one really learns that
language and it is like the foundation of a
great Universe of things that can be
do with that language eh when one
look for example what Edge is
javascript computing back is the
language when one looks at how it emerged
serverless no js And javascript was the
first runtime in that world when one
look what you can do with react Ned
when you look at what you can do with
nextjs how you learn a language and
Open all the doors of the world and I believe
that now with what is coming
Artificial intelligence something that
It attracts a lot of attention. How good it is.
the Ai in writing javascript is like
that javascript is the gift
that one always receives eh and that only
it gets better over time
Thank you very much a
applause then talking about this topic
that is in the Mouth of everyone and all
companies How how do you see apart from
help us developers
to write code How else do you see the paper
of artificial intelligence in everything
what is web development and evolution
of technology
currently well first what is always
I say it is when one enters through
first time the world
programming It is really a very challenging
very
great I had to spend years and years and
years breaking my head trying to
understand how a closure works and how
the syntax works and it is difficult to
everyone the first thing I
very excited about Intelligence
artificial is that it will continue
equalizing access to information
access to learn new things gives me
jealousy really thinking about the child or the
girl who wants to learn today
javascript and it has chpt which I don't
I had at that moment So I think let's go
to see a very large acceleration of it
access of different people to the
world and the industry
programming That is the most basic thing
I'm more excited on the other hand, I think
what are we going to do? we are getting into a
world where we are bringing me never
I liked the peer programming here I remember
When I arrived in Silicon Valley, everything
the world is excited that
you shared the screen and two people
They worked at the same time for me
It seemed and there are many people who serve
Personally it never helped me
It seemed like it was invasive to me.
the rhythm of the two had to be coordinated
people was like a fad
Let's say but I think that with the Ai Now
Yes, that is the vision that many had.
what we were going to program
with another person in quotes who
he is assisting us at all times and he is helping us
giving ideas and suggesting us and
capturing errors I think that will
be the future of all professions
not just programming and opportunity
very big for all those who are with us
listening now and and everyone
we are in this room and with myself
included It's really learning how
collaborate better with intelligence
artificial No it's not that they are going to be
from one day to the next we naturally
finish all the work
hey I close the text editor I'm going to
I'm going to relax in Santa Marta eh Me
I would love to but there really is
have to perfect how to work with those
artificial intelligences How to do the
prompting in What things are strong in
What things are weak even huh
develop an instinct for when they are
intelligences wrong
artificial ones are not perfect Eh
so and and obviously the great
opportunity for everyone who likes
making products and entrepreneurship is
make products with Intelligence
artificial today to give you a
example in bersel we are always
looking for how we can buy some
product that improves our productivity
internal with artificial intelligence and
A few days ago I was meeting with
many of the CEOs of the most important companies
greatest technology companies in the world that were
an event in in San Francisco
related to relationships with
with China and everyone tells me what
I want to purchase products myself
related to in artificial then
for those who are today
undertaking has opened one of the
biggest opportunities
century Thanks a round of applause for
please good next
nextjs has obviously become
one of the full stack frameworks
facto in react Who causes next
Raise your hand Oops I wish I could see the
number of people who are raising the
hand at this moment
hey tell us a little bit about sneak peak
of which priorities in which the
next team is working now and
what's coming for nextjs in the
future
uh the most what is most important
for us now and we had it in the
conference is performance something that
It's really a problem that I
love that we have is that the
next applications are doing more and more
bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger and we are working on something
which excites me very much because
It is a project that took a long time and
it takes a long time because the
engineering difficulty is very very
big but it's this compiler
incremental that we are uh including
like a new engine that will enhance
the cli the next the the the the server
next development and pipeline
make builds for production of next and
never in the industry Beyond Google
and goal never in the industry has
there was a compiler of these categories
that is Open source and that it is very easy
to configure it to be instantaneous and
What does this compiler basically do?
is turbopac is when it is very similar
Artificial intelligence When someone
in your group perform a task
example a page in the developed
development server next and the and the
compilation job to render the
Imagine if your colleague who is going to open
that same page in the future does not have
to do that work back there
a global Cash that says oh and someone
did that task in another part of the world or
to my colleague on the other side of the
office and I think that will improve the
everyone's productivity because
It's one thing to compile very quickly and that's what
we are doing we are also going to
promote rust at a conference
javascript Don't kill me but we are
rewriting the compiler in a
native language that is very very fast
but that's not enough either because
the applications are being so and so
great and I believe that Intelligence
artificial is going to accelerate what is there
too much code to compile into
world So we're taking that
strategy is how to be smart
It's like reusing work, it's like being
vague in some way but by and by
have a positive result that
performance is something I always
He was excited, eh. In fact, I've been thinking.
about this problem 8 years ago and I think
that this is going to be one of the greats
moments for for the next project and
for other projects that will be able
also use it when
future Thank you very much another round of applause for
William for
favor was Let's go a little for him
Back nojs has been the let's say the bookstore
or the de facto Run Time for projects
backend But lately they have
appeared several r Times we have bon
we have deno that well obviously they have
fact that the entire ecosystem also
start evolving what your vision is
your vision of how the world would evolve
come development with javascript what is it
that world
ideal
I believe that the ideal world is one in which
that the developer does not have to
worry too much about what I'm doing
backend I'm doing frontend actually
on Twitter fights begin about what it is
backend and what is frontend but the
backend is better than frontend
frontend is better than backend my
Vision is very clear, it must be done
Good products for people must be
make pages load very fast
in fact in this group eh confidential
let's say I always think we have to
To beat Apple you have to beat Team
Cook You have to remove the applications
natives you have to put the web in all
sides So I always think let's do it
products that charge fast haos
products that are truly global
I load it in Colombia I load it in
Argentina Loaded it in Sao Pablo Loaded it
in San Francisco and load
snapshot So I always think
From that perspective backwards one of
the things you've really had
a lot of impact on the world is that
we have made frameworks in it is a
framework there are other frameworks
excellent as is belkit and nax and remex
etc. these frameworks allow
make sure, let's say on a large scale, that the
vast majority of people by default
make quick applications So it's
like we start from what are the
things we need serc for
product to chip something great
So we go to a layer towards
Behind is the framework and there you start
with the frontend not the first thing you do
to make a quick application
interactive is the frontend but the
frontend needs to bring Data needs
perform data transformation processes
you need to do authentication processes
that's where the layer comes from behind
something that is very good that I think
What's happening now is that the frontend and
the backend are starting to get closer
does not mean that there will not be
Separate backends but the style of
programming the way to connect that
frontend securely and fitly
performante is approaching the backend
Why is it approaching the backend?
because there has to be little latency
So when you see new features
in xs like server actions like the
possibility of loading data directly
in the server components what is
very good that's what we are putting
render component where
corresponds, for example, to the side of the
my squel database next to the
post database next to some
microservice in the cloud for example is
very important to put the rendering of
a
as close as possible to the model
of language whether you use Open Ai
In other words, this perspective applies to everything
the world has to put things close and
another thing we are putting close is
the way to write these applications
because now I can
write access data direct
inside my react component that's for
me is the great new paradigm that
even yesterday on Twitter he follows him
opening the minds of many people
that in fact for maybe people like
Julián or Juan Pablo we are in this
world of comings and goings and
technology pendulum 20 ago
capable years does not surprise us so much because
when we wrote php it was very
similar to that not now the layer more
Below everything is the runtime that is there
d is boon there d is deno and it is a
very important layer because any
performance that improves to that improves to
that whole stack of applications that
we went over what I described
So if, for example, Boom becomes more
everything is done faster not because
I'm going to render the Front faster
access the fastest data in the world
backend so I'm very excited about it
that but what I always recommend to the
world is you have to think in shape
holistic you have to think about the whole
the battery and you have to think how to give it the
best possible result
user Thank you very much another applause for
William
[Music]
Guillermo really thanks for
join us now to finish as
jsconf around the world has always been
a conference to inspire
motivate eh what last words do you have
for all the attendees who are here
eh so that they are motivated to create
share create community products
What words do you have from your experience?
we were just talking about php and recently in
Twitter may have seen a meme that
It started to go viral that it was people
uploaded photos of their vehicles and someone
say photo a Lamborghini says Thank you php
and another person uploaded a photo of a Toyota and says
Thanks Java etc. I think
really the possibilities that one
Open programming and programming to the world
product programming and javascript
They are really amazing it goes beyond
The material goes beyond whether it is a
vehicle if it is an opportunity to go to
another part of the world if it is a
opportunity to create a company
local if it is a form of I loved it
What did Julián say about integrating more
people to the industry eh all of these
doors are going to open with software one
you're going to have to know how to manipulate that
software Sometimes it is reusing the software
sometimes I remember when it was
boy thought you had to write
all the lines of code and and one day I
opened the world of the open
source and see that I could forge code that
I could integrate code then the
idea is to amplify the impact that one
has on the world and software is the
fastest way to amplify that
impact is free eh I always say
It's amazing that one can go to github and
clone all these examples
templates
deploy them in this global community
You sent me a zoom link and
now I'm connected with you eh Me
They send a message on Twitter and I see their
products eh write an an article
incredible and I'm going to read it in hacker news
we are all there in that in that arena
everyone connected there and that excites me
very much because it will continue
accelerating and there's going to be more of that
to have more opportunities in the future
Artificial Intelligence really helps us
will accelerate dramatically back
I'm jealous of people who are
starting today because it is going to have these
opportunities to have these co-pilots AND
these vzero and this documentation and the
gpt chat and he's really going to send us
to the clouds so stay on
contact I send you a big hug and
let's continue creating products and events like
this one that really brings the community together and
they take us to the future Thank you very much
Guillermo a round of applause for Guillermo
r
Excellent very very good Guillermo already
you can continue with your super busy day
We will continue celebrating
the last jcf in Colombia So let's go
getting ready because obviously we are going to
have more opinions more experts
sharing your knowledge But this
maybe we will be able to have them here
in our panel So we're going to have
as I told you this morning we are going to have
three panel let's let's start with
backend then we will have a panel
frontend And finally we are going to have
that panel is going to be later
we are going to have a panel now of everything
is he
local development ecosystem then
I would like to invite
stage to the following speakers to
the panel called navig
back
[Applause]
to the stage Juan
grove stage ra
gz
and Last but not least Ricardo
[Music]
castle and we will have as a moderator
to the person in charge of all the content of the
conference that is Mr. Adrián
Estrada applauds Adrián for
[Applause]
please okay oh let's sit here
Very nice cushion. Hey, I can do it.
carry huh
We don't need it right now anymore eh first
that everything because I am very happy to be
here with these great developers
baken all Latin Americans for me it is
a pride to see
this we are going to talk about what javascript is
in it
baken these days can respond to
Rafa and Eric who speak Portuguese
Could you respond in English if you are not there?
comfortable in Spanish eh feel free
Well, respond however you want then.
well the first topic we are going to talk about
It's about performance when we're
developing javascript one in the database
of the most important performance topics
So what are the main ones?
performance considerations when using
javascript for
develop in the
baken let's start with Eric Hello good
days Colombia
[Applause]
yeah so well This is iak pe about my
Talk right my Talk is how you can
consumes gigabytes of Data in javascript
right All About performing the mistake
I see in javascript is people trying to
eat from other languages ​​and thinking
that well javascript is low Now What's
going on So The goal of javascript is to
process Data on demand So You can
process terabytes of Data if you need
But You can process all theand so Uh I I
would say What gilero said in his speech
right now he was like well we have
standard apis and Whatever javascript is
running there If It's the javascript
standard the performance is going to be
exactly similar but You're going to have
the
nice Thank you okay let's go then with
Juan Tell me Juan, what do you think?
oh
In principle, no one cared
both performance in javascript
Dear that clear then it began to be
important either for other runtimes or
because people think it's important
eh I have seen why I don't know performance
Aha I have seen
eh a lot of tricks a lot of tricks
I don't know using prototypes and not classes
avoiding the Sugar syntax to have
more efficient results sometimes eh
Another thing I've seen is we know that in
Note There is a problem with http
true Oh and you search for example eh the
sockets are implemented in the layer
of javascript which is a little bit
inefficient sometimes it's looking I don't know
suddenly make a mix to make more
efficient the http socket but at its
Maybe he's in another problem
made in javascript so that more
people could contribute and watch them
the layer is that there are a lot of
concerns Okay what do you think
Raphael
it's so
well How do I Start basically Uh the
main issue When we look to the
performance issues Uh Talking About nojs
for instance is the Bad platform usage
so for instance if you block the event
Loop Don't do that please Uh if you
consume um if you perform a lot of
assist calls you need to turn your
application to accept that increasing
the threads and Yes nojs uses threads by
the way Uh and well login It's Uh
normally I Thing That affects tons of
applications nowadays Uh and but most of
the Bot Uh lives in the business model
if you just load all your database in a
single variable you know that it won't
work right so yeah We have a lot of
things that we can play with with no js
but really is Jess it depends it depends
on your applic If application consumes
tons of you need to look at your
application in a different way more
Memory
specialized cpu intensive Maybe you
should use us I don't know and it
OK
I am rich
nervous, just as they mentioned, there is a
concept that we can handle
developing in backen what is it
we can control F outside the
runtime Because if we use true
runtime Ban den or node eh our
responsibility for that is for example
be able to use patterns that help us
optimize certain processes I have seen
many applications that are
instantiating classes or situations in
number of times agree when
the requests arrive so there is a
pattern they are not implementing as
a single to be able to maintain
just that eh How do we know node es
a single thread So we have to
try to avoid how to generate this
blockage and for that one of the
main recommendations will always
be try to use singaw try
use promises and sometimes there are
burden that we do not need to leave to the
language as such we can use another
tool eh inside that is the
memory management
certain requests and that we can
implement things like redis or something else
other services to be able to manage the
cache we do not need to dedicate ourselves
full to give that responsibility to
language when other technology can
do We have responsibilities on the
language Yes and there are things that we have to
optimize yes in that is algorithms
patterns and avoid doing a for Loop
eternal that will consume us all
memory Thank you very much okay Well let's go
to make a follow up of a topic that
I was trying to r a moment ago huh
but let's take it one more level
technician more I want to know your
opinions we are going to ask ourselves in your
individual experience you what
think about the new runtime
of alternatives like deno as B s in
comparison with node qu strengths and what
disadvantages you see
chaos well I've been searching a lot
right I I'm Going To show a lot of the
Stuff like recreating nojs from Scratch
like I downloaded All the to understand
Why We have so many runtimes appearing
and in the end people I know in brazil
I've seen people freaking Oh my God no
Die Now
I think this competition Amazing for Our
ecosem like for Us Being part of nojs
we've seen like the users are reaching
out more Now we say well we need this in
nojs well we've seen that a lot of
features are going nojs for a While and
people say W nojs copy this from Dino B
copy from nojs and so on and so Forth
but in the end We are trying to find a
the same Api for them It's Again What gl
said When we have a standard Api it
It doesn't matter we can use On Google Our
javascript project and Google would say
well I'm Going To use this Amazon would
say I'm Going To use other so the the
whole Thing for me is we need Those Run
Times to Keep pushing Us Forward and
show that we can improve Uh Just in
summary We have a working Group
allun and they Are Not cing each other
they are not fighting each other They are
collaborating are saying well we sol
this with this algorithm try this in us
Because nojs c+ this would be better in
c+ Plus so It's all part of a Group so
no Fight at Okay thank you
you a
see I like that others exist
runtimes but at the same time
I think they are also a problem
Oh and one of the problems is they break the
ecosystem all new Run Times
without exception they had to implement
npm all scratched from all cracked from
package manager and now they all support
in p all without exception So I don't
I think that
u I don't think so that a r Time
can be better than another if it is not
generally adopted by industry
it is always the industry that demands
features things and sometimes more than the
efficiency the speed of this or that
runtime is come on I have a lot of
tooling from years ago that I can't
break out with a new Run Time though
I like the working Group rgc thing I think
what is called that what you are looking for is to close
the gap and create a standard Ah a
standard luck between rong times And so on
there will come a time when
it will take many years because we love it
argue
Ah where you are finally going to say you know
what I want this rtin over this other
not because it is written in rust or c+
but because it is my preference and
It fits my model better but not because
It has a feature that another does not
Ok well actually I I love the new
runtimes We have Now lot of Run Times
based on nojs and particularly is good
to have it for the entire System Because
people try things
buts basic better test for nojs If It's
working there Why not implementing nojs
I'm just kidding but that That's That's
A Way that it can work he wants chaos I
knew
Uh and well Uh It was good Because we
Saw that for instance Ban implemented
Dino implemented buting tested and nojs
implemented it as well Because It was
working fine and the the mentality of
nojs the Team has changed after this
this New Run Times We are Now accepting
New modules I Yesterday I proposed the
new module for nojs Which I believe that
If I propose it years ago I would be
rejected in the First moment Uh yeah for
Sure and Uh I think That's Great Because
We are Now hearing more the
Community and we Are creating Uh no.js
or uh uh improving nojs based on the
user feedback Which Which should be the
the main reason for it exists
rardo on my side I love that there is
a lot of runtime that appears a lot
runtime this mainly because I
I see how on a basis of how the
economy the economy improves based on the
competition You could say when not
there is a monopoly but in the case of
technologies such as
runtime When there is acceleration of
development on one the other will
try to improve even more to be better
that he then that healthy competition
helps innovation growth
technology happens the same thing that happened with
all de fren frameworks started
to improve according to how they were going
improving others because they wanted to be
better than him deno was very focused on
security concepts that's why it was born
based on what did not have a node in a
principle they go with the concept that it is
much more optimal at the level of
processing now clear all this
It can be like this now And maybe in a year
More Noah maybe will improve all
security issues eh he's going to beat
deno after deno is going to beat van
then van is going to beat node and
maybe later a fourth will appear
runtime but this competition makes
innovation in technology grows and
There is a topic that is very important and it is
the community about technology and today
Nowadays, Node is the one who has the biggest
matured at the community level and
has the greatest adaptation to migrate from a
runtime to another nowadays is super
complex especially with platforms that
They are very robust, very large, so
as long as that community is not followed
moving towards the others runtime It is a
little difficult for it to continue growing so
fast as it's doing, not almost
is releasing one version two versions
by year
basically Thank you very much okay you played
a very important topic we are going to talk about
a little bit of security yes eh then
What are the main challenges for
ensure security when implementing
javascript in the Back with node
Uh It's I would say It's it depends on
the kind of application right um I think
we Miss we as developers we Miss like a
checkpoint I would say more the part of
the user When we're Going To deliver Our
software We should have like Oh is this
protected from sql injection is this
protected from like js paring or
encoding errors so sometimes Just
thinking let's deliver and let's see
this is an mvp and we're going to check
this out later and then we face the
problem so I would say
Uh this would be It's Because this is
Pretty hard to Tell right Because
depending on the framework each
different framework We have Will have a
set of functions but they Are Not Bullet
proof If they saved Us from All the
problems Our application probably is
going to be slower or we're going to
lose a lot of stuff right so I would say
the Security that We have on nojs Now Uh
as probably Rafa is going to Tell you so
I won't spoiler What is going to Tell
about Security right but It's nojs is
increasing and improving New features I
don't know if people are seeing how
Those apis are be implemented there but
I would say the Run Time Is there to
help Us but we as developers we should
think of well What This is what is the
minimum for
Okay let's go with
Juan I also think that as
developers We have to have very
introduce the security issue i in Note
I have generally seen vulnerabilities
of the javascript language, not so much of the
runtime like all of them because you use reeps and it
you are using wrong
or node dependencies like Open ssl that
has vulnerabilities and and what
We do It's every Security relas get
the patches
security but note to me personally
I
It seems pretty safe or is it true?
although you have to
have as your shield let's always say
It's how you use helmet when you use htt
because they are headers that protect you, no
They have nothing to do with the r but with the
protocol or I insist dependencies Dey are
those who are vulnerable and not so much the r
it has very rarely had to be patched
the good r
peraj
a Main issue When we deal with nojs is
that If We make a Security feature We
are We are Breaking the word right like
we cannot we cannot create a feature by
the F for instance Who Who knows Dino
raise the hand Oh That's Great no
one but
basically When Dino was released One of
the main features is I can Uh restrict
access to the environment so If I don't
want to have Access to my H folder I
won't have Access unless I explicitly
Send the the the
flag node nowadays contains that flag I
Uh We have implemented that on nojs It's
called permission model It's currently
experimental but I really recommend you
if you use no.js to test it in your
Machine and and as I said the main
Problem is Uh We are Breaking the word
we cannot turn this flag Uh on by the
otherwise
I expect tons of companies Open issues
to no js complaining about that Because
their software is not working the latest
version of nojs so the main issue is
Because we need to Support Legacy and
That's Uh That's terrible Uh and One
important thing to mention is I normally
assess and receive All the hacker One
reports we receive on nojs so if you
find A vulnerability On nojs we report I
review that and and If that gets
accepted you receive a bount Uh like a
lot of money $or
something and Uh most of the Target of
the hackers are developers and not
Production users
so please be careful when you go to a
handle tutorial or YouTube video that
tells you to install a Magic package
normally this Magic package is not so
Magic so yeah That's
Item
I agree with everything
They said And to that I'm going to the point that
security is actually part of the
developers and to fairly maintain
optimized eh what they had mentioned no
be with the p dependency that are
with a year ago two years ago many
patches are already out but we are
updating dependencies like that
we forgot to update
dependencies that we are using eh And
I know this because there is a project in which
which has soap in version 0.4
So it's horrible but eh
security although it goes on the side of
language eh that at the language level
he has still been working a lot
javascript to be able to solve certain
certain things that are appearing but
there is a super big competition with
what the same hackers are doing or
who are trying to find out how
these vulnerabilities And you have a lot
people attacking to find
new holes
eh and carry like the the the same
speed is super complex because
apart from trying to find
ways to cover up those flaws
security you are also generating new
uh new features to improve the
language then follow the
competition is very complex and always
there are going to be perforations
security there will always be
injection and a sinf of etcetera then
we have to put on the patch a little
before the wound eh at the level
server have very well structured
security issue eh today there is a
endless etcetera that we can use
services to do just that and move away and
block the entrance a little to the
servers to break
certain things the typical use waf eh
be blocking DS attacks by
the same thing, avoid sql injection and
please avoid sensitive data
outwardly it is a responsibility
superca and one is sometimes consulting
certain sites and they return you
extremely sensitive information that
you could do a lot of damage with it
So we are returning any
thing and security starts precisely from
we as developers
language already gives us parts of security
but if we don't use it, it's our fault
ours is very right Okay we have
little time so the last question
It is about the uses of javascript in the
They seem to have seen lately that
are very innovative. So there has been
normal use has come out yes what
en well I would say for Any javascript
applications but the ability Again my be
soon but the ability of processing
videos audios on demand with javascript
so just a brief example Some people like
when you upload a video usually can save
this video on the dis and then you can
upload later but with no js you can
receive this foot of video you can
process it you can upload this without
even have to save on the on the disk So
You save a lot of processing Power and a
lot of disks so for me This is one of
the best things We can do with nojs
which is Pretty hard with other languages
Okay Ju quickly
electron electron or incredible pair
be able to run native applications in
using javascript and oh what would be the
ionic equivalent I don't know I love that
javascript can now run almost on
anywhere
by well electr is a very good package
for inst Who no J Production here raise
the
hand Who use slack With Your
Company js
productions discord is no js notion is
no js One password is no js so That's
all based on electron
js Innovation in javascript is in
everywhere today we can do
everything Mobile eh desk eh web servers eh
uh the typical thing we do with arduino or
things that are more more home with
connections with Alexa that kind of thing
eh And eh today it is being seen a lot
work with us But focused as a
real-time visualization and
3D visualization eh To be able
work with 3D images and
making 3D videos eh There is a
chatter who is always there to chat
yarat that is always innovating
precisely in this and recently it went up
also a video on how to work with
the hand gestures to be able to do
movement with javascript then eh
We have innovation and there is everything but
I have seen a lot with the audio issue
video and 3D we are working a lot on
That's a very interesting point. Well,
I want to thank you for being here with
us and participate and give us their
personal opinions that are very eh
appreciated And thank you very much We follow each other
seeing
[Applause]
thank you Thank you very much that this
these experts here
as tough as we say here in
Colombia How would you translate that?
Adrián u m talented talented no but
but in Spanish talented in English in
english Oops Ah u it's difficult unskilled
skill can be a
like like I don't think it covers the essence
Yes what is the word
teso Let's continue with another panel
what is the frontend panel and after
of the panel there is going to be an activity
Do you remember that I told you that we were going to
do something after the panel
It's obviously lunch. How delicious we are.
to eat but before we all
let's go to lunch we're going to go to
take the group photo and remember that the
photo is super important because this is
the last one and we are a lot of people
So Ah let's coordinate some
logistics so that we can
take that photo let's go out organized
It's going to be here in front of the treasury now
They are preparing and organizing the place
so that they do not leave so that they remain in
the photo is going to be difficult as well as where
is Javier or where is waldo so that
are found but so that we have that
nice memory ready I count on you
so that we are well organized to
the photo now and we are inviting the
people on the next panel Adrián was very
wisely the list was given to me and I was
It lost but I already have it here. So
let's call the stage here now
our frontend experts
ui the panel title is called emerging
trends in the javascript ui
sand let's call Juan Caicedo Juan
Caicedo please a
[Applause]
applause sider Palacios sider please come
for
here we also have Juan Guillermo
Murillo Where is Juan Guillermo a
applause for Juan
Guillermo And finally malba Martín
manriquez come here so yes put him
point 75 to the answer to
that there is no fan we are here with
good weather And we have again
our moderator adriá Estrada and
we have our frontend experts
you can start well first Many
thank you for being here hey we want
discuss uh what development is with
Front these days Eh the innovations
that we must obviously take advantage of all
the experience that you in the
field eh let's discuss Starting with
the trends yes we want to know you
What do you think? What are the innovations?
most significant in javascript in this
moment in the Front field let's start
so malma Hello hello Now more
calm down don't stop I'm drugged yes
quiet pressure my throat hurts
but it hurts me more to program in
php eh No, the truth is that
lately there have been many
javascript side updates
first from the appearance part
of react there have been many
updates from the
server site rendering the part of the
components the part of the Shadow dum Y
lately what has come is
precisely the page generation
static way what we
we would know as the State site
generation that comes very hand in hand with
the Jam stack with everything that is
hamess cms and on the other hand also
we have what are the apis of
Browsers optimized as you can
be webs speake for all part of
natural language processing from
the browser side and therefore all
handlers the progress and web Apps and
What is the State manager? To go
working what is are the states in
from the browser side then the
innovation goes towards that part where
start integrating between the backend and the
frontend and increasingly the line is more
thin where suddenly we see that
we have micro micro frontends where
We also have what would be a Server s
small rendering for example with what
it would be hdra and there we see that we have like
running several things and we optimize the
frontend to make ca more easily
So right now we are like in a
strange moment where suddenly
frontend is just getting closer
towards Machine learning towards the part
of Mathematics, Big Data but without
leave aside the approach that follows
constantly towards the backend and
also the innovation towards the side
of the user experience is something that has gone
improving and libraries for
animations visualizations have gone
getting better
perfect Don Guillermo Aló
eh Well, in terms of Innovation
package library themes Well
I feel like it's been a lot, for example.
In the case of frameworks, well
focused on the additional ui to react Well
which has been coming for a couple of years now
came out quick solid Astro and a lot of
new frameworks that they already have
additional to a Well, to this whole topic of
the hooks already come integrating signals and
other things like as well cool
eh And let's say on the side, well, of the
of the user experience as such eh
Let's say that leaving the topic aside
of the frameworks and the code I feel
that this discussion between Search eh or
search versus chat interface is going to be
like uh revolutionary in terms of
everything that is bringing us these
Language models
Why Because the users come
accustomed to a different interaction
to click to write to search and these
chat models come to change a
little let's say that the paradigm let's say
that chat is not something new per se or
either we have been chatting since
So it's been a good time but no
with a machine and not in such a way
natural So let's say in the area of
customer service in in in many areas
make a Revolution and already many
companies are looking for how to implement
these chat interface in a more way
quick So for example I don't know if they have
seen that there is a package of vercel
which is called Ai and literally with a
Hook and a couple of things you integrate with
a model like chat gpt or
any hing Face model is a
Absurd thing then I feel that for
That side there is a lot of fabric to cut
OK
well thanks
No
no good of the trends anymore
interesting that I see that they are in the
language arriving It's the whole issue of
microfrontends with module theme
federation the web assembly theme that
Unlock model deployment
from Front to let them run directly into
the browser
user also interested me a lot and
The pwa issue made my head explode
eh For example I implemented recently
even for this this conference uh a
copilot for a demo in that copilot eh
basically implement quite a bit of what
It has to do with the issue of promises.
issue of generators and combining them
you can do quite a few things
interesting then things are how
which I would think are in trend
now create interfaces
eh guided by co-pilots for some reason
kind of co-pilot whatever
Power some Intelligence model
artificial style ch gpt or or something a
little simpler but all the
future Very good thank you Don Juan and
and my theme is a very classic theme
I think but a topic that has advanced
a lot in the industry, I think it is
test uh the tools to be able to
do javascript tests those who knew
what Tests were before in selenium
like loading a server and seeing the
page that was very complex nowadays
There are many tools to do
test at different levels eh at the level of
of unit to execute a code and one see
how it works at the integration level
be able to load page elements and
interact with them but not from
visually but also on a server
that one can execute eh quickly and
see behavior in a way that
creates ease of modifying and viewing
how the code works eh And also
Well, there are tools to see the
code visually if yes it looks like
should be seen with which one can e
create like those acceptance tests
much easier and it seems to me that
It makes our work much easier and
so we can understand the behavior
of much better code then I
It seems that this is the aspect that most
is improving our industry and that
Much more tools excite me
yes okay let's continue then with another topic
see There are a lot of frameworks and
tools we were talking a little
about them but at this moment I
I want you to tell me about the
favorite tool and which ones
would you recommend to address the
current challenges to implement ui AND
why with bad Ah something to keep in mind
counts when we are going to choose a
framework is how robust it is how
flexible is And if it has support from the
community something that has happened throughout
of time and they won't let me
lie many frameworks come out all the time
time it was my turn in a company that
we started working with feus because one
one of the react contributors took it out and
It was like Boom is going to be the framework
of frameworks and we grabbed it and both
months they stopped giving maintenance
So the project was like Okay now.
we did it we have a fart what are we going to do
do so we are going to give maintenance to
we then have to take into account
consider those aspects possibly seen
which is gold but if we are in the
desert is of no use to us, gold we need
water then we need a framework
that adapts to our needs
meets the requirements that
we are looking for and above all that you have
a support either from a community or from
a very big company but still not
There is certainty that he will remain alive and
example of that is polymer polymer Google
He painted it very well and it worked cool with
his allies but suddenly said I know what
this is where polymer arrived in the version
two will be in the dead projects
And suddenly you realize that although
There are frameworks or libraries that
They have support from companies like Google
that still has the risk of
that suddenly they stop giving
maintenance and enter right at the
nonsense of projects that no longer give them
maintenance in particular to me
I really like working with vjs because it is
a mix between react and angular angular
It looks like a box of Legos to me.
you have pieces that come together in one
way very well but when you want
doing something more custom is going to cost you
work you have you have to cut those
Lego pieces and on the other hand react is
Like plasticine it is very flexible but the
the fact that it's so flexible all of a sudden
brings problems because if they don't have
good engineering standards and
they begin to combine many technologies
they put moex in it, they put redux in it
someone uses states someone generates
components by classes others by
functions you have a huge monster there
that maintaining it is ugly and doing
a version migration when you
code is horrible it's double
difficult Very good thanks Juan Guillermo
Hello good
and particularly let's say Beyond
the frameworks and I would like
comment on a problem that has happened to me
followed lately I don't know if you
I also think so and it is the
communication between design and development
It's super complex, it's like on the one hand
you have to wait for them to block you
the design Because surely it has
happened like three times in my life and I think
that this was the last one, the third one
Well, they pass me the figma, I don't know. Ready now.
Go ahead
I'm going to program component by
component I already have tests I mean now
I have everything ready and in a week well
the next two weeks arrives
designer and he tells me Oh I have the new one
version I already received feedback and I like this
The design was not blocked then
It has happened to me three times, the last one was
a month ago so it's a little let's say
annoying but it's not the fault of the
designer because well they too
They must receive feedback and in the end
of the day, let's say the objective is that
be the best experience for the user
What am I going with all this in that a
bookstore which may be a little
underrated it is a storybook I don't know if they have it
heard but we use it in
Well, in the Atlan project and it is a
wonder because well it is a wonder
and it's a headache sometimes too
because one says well if I have to
implement this component quick Ay
but the storybooks But well, one
Let's say the shot catches him and
It seems wonderful to me because, well,
those who are not familiar with
storybook one let's say it renders the
View react component I think
supports multiple multiple libraries
frameworks and additionally you can
add all the variations that
have that component Then at the end
of the day you have all the variations
either text eh feature Flags By
example if you are handling feature Flags
in a component to validate that it does not
you're breaking let's say eh a
existing behavior and being
working Well the new behavior
I think it's super cool and this at the end
it generates you like literally a
documentation that can be shared with
the designer Then the designer
end of the day you will have the real list
of the components that exist AND
Additionally, the list of
library of components that you already use
be it internal or material or some
external So this combination you already
the designer already knows exactly what
component exists because sometimes
They say like Oh, this component is here.
So I don't like them but that's not a
component as such was something that
built as a custom Eh well you
It has But you are late So it is
storybook Okay thanks
ready sider inside the Great Aveno of the
javascript ecosystem and
tools that exist I would believe that
the most important thing is to really sit down
to analyze what is most convenient
for your project With what
tool serves more to give
solution to your project for example such
Maybe it makes sense to use react for
performance maybe it makes sense
use grael for the cache issue or
the topic
communication between Back
Front or simple It simply has more
sense to do something like
a compose like what they do js
So I would recommend first before
to jump headfirst, don't do it and
analyze well what is most convenient
for your particular problem very good Ju
I think there is no such thing as an answer.
always exact, I think exactly as
Snider says it all depends on the context and
of many times of the problem that one
want to solve What tools do you have
what to use or sometimes it has nothing to do
For example, in my company we use
mostly next but the application
center where I work is all
client Side then next would be
true the wrong decision but it is
a decision that works for the
entire organization and function as
organization is more important than
technical decision at that time So
I think the most important thing is how
each developer as
We have to generate our own opinions and
tastes of how to create useful patterns
reusable and that communicate ideas with
other developers because it seems to me
that ends up affecting the code and the
behavior more than any
framework decision eh And it's more Me
I think that with any framework one can
do things very well and very badly
then it seems to me that one knows
analyze what is working AND how
guiding it in another direction is more
important that what we are
receiving from
frameworks Very good thanks Juan
Guillermo, you touched on a very important topic.
uh that whole battle between design and
implementation of the UI design and
implementation as such and the iux eh is
question is how do they balance the need
of a rich user interface eh and
attractive with optimization
performance and functionality
the design implemented yes Well here it is
as several concepts to take into account
and usually it seems that we are
fought as well as developers and
graphic designers but you have to
understand also us how they
they work and how they think and so do they
They have to get into the code and see how
we work because suddenly there is
like this dissonance where they give you
a super complex design so that
do it in one day and that's how doubtful
it has too many animations it is not going to
leave in one day if you want it comes out in
year and a half
So yes no but within things
What we can do is first we can
take a little tutorial there on YouTube
or a course there in Platzi de figma for
understand how it works give us an idea
about what their work is like and about the
designer understand a little the part of the
code there is a phrase that I really like
what is you don't need to learn to
write to be a great writer but
to know what the writing is about and
be able to communicate and in the code it is
exactly the same if we
we learn to program maybe not
we would be an Einstein of programming
But we can create things we can
solve problems with the code and
within the things we can do
to nurture a ui is the part of
minimize and compress assets we can
work with what is acy loading
so we can load the elements
an acceptable way and works well
we can work What are the way
efficient animations which is something
which costs a lot of resources in the
browser and something that happens later is that
we have many library dependencies
that we don't need And suddenly for a
simple animation that we can get with
a transform or a basic property of
ccs we add javascript libraries
like this to the beast then we have to check
a lot of that to have a design
responsible appropriate management
adequate of the State because the State
the part also becomes inefficient
of a ui eh and an intuitive ux and
simple above all and the optimization of
the apis there are times that even
we consume apis everywhere and perhaps
with a single fitch that we can make and
knowing how to distribute it through the
local memory we can work in one
appropriately but suddenly not
We really know how to handle
local memory The cache is saturated And
suddenly we have to do a lot of
requests duplicating information that already
We had So I would recommend
Oh well, they are like investigating a
little bit of design side and also this
yex optimization part because of
one way or another it comes to serve us
to have a better project or job
of
additional agreement to this part since
communication in well in me
experience has also served me well
how to talk to him with the designer or
designer constantly and let's say
explain more or less how they are going
the imp working Eh well the
implementations
eh Also agree with with optimize
from the code what I have seen
it works let's say faster is the
image compression, that is, it is something that
It doesn't cost us anything as developers.
there are pages that one visits and delays
a lot of carrying and one looks at the
resources that are downloading and are
like 18 megabytes and 10 megabytes are images
then one says like what is happening
here for that particular case because one
can be done manually but they already exist
integrated cms to which you
you can ask for the image of a Wi
particular or of a particular quality
2x And you are then for macbook 1x if it is
computer
additional normal to Lazy loading
dynamic imports for packages that o
components you are not using yet
Well there is no need to
download them and there is one because I missed it
at the moment but safely in
mdm can find the specification
there is a there is an image a component of
image that
He supports you passing him an image I think
what is image souret an image
depending on the with then
particularly for Mobile it is very useful
because then you can define well
I don't need to load the image of 100
pixels on a mobile device Then
If it is from 320 to 580 or 720, what is a tablet?
upload this image which is much more
much smaller light weight and in fact
It fits more to the design that usually happens
Thank you, complementing what you just said.
say my partner eh We could also
use balancing techniques
resources as the user
require, I give you a specific example.
I remember a few years ago when they came out
Apple's airpods Max eh to them
They had a website where they showed it
so they had super heavy images
videos in four ocayo always likes it
have the highest quality in everything then
uh what they did was that as the
user scrolled they were loading
resources also have meaning
common and do Well think about where you are going
the user click and maybe do a
prefetch of the resources that the user
you're going to need it in the future eh too
code splitting module techniques
federation or servers components so that
the user can see and most of all in
mobile barely loads the page something that doesn't
Simply load the page and see a
a loading not that I once saw
information see content Okay thanks
Juan and Yes, I very much agree with those who
they went to my talk yesterday first
Thank you very much the other thing is that what
I showed what it was to make a page with
many animations in javascript very
complex that I do not recommend
eh For example Apple now I think that in
At one time they used that style of
technique and now they no longer use it because
Pages like this require a lot and no no
create the best experience when you are
loading everything very slow So I think
that in general the images the more
little ones the better the less the better everything
what can be done with css instead
with javascript also very good eh And
I think in general like like
developers if we want to do things
eh Because we have the ability because
we have the the tools is not the
better decision and instead of doing the
Simpler things create more flexibility
in the future Okay now to finish eh
There is an issue that is complex to handle
eh what exists in the development of the Front
What is framework fatigue?
hey many appear and we have
to deal with it how do you handle it
this concept of framework fatigue
How do you decide on this issue? Yes,
Once that is done, it has already happened to us that
soon we use a framework like
angular and for for the certain
activities that we are working on are not going
according then normally what
We do It is a replanning of the
architecture of how we are
using services as they are
components distributed and
mainly how are we going to make a
migration if it is required to do a
migration for what we need to do
and something we have to take into account
is that there are some technologies that are
emerging that are not yet 100%
adapted for some frameworks
So if we want to add webgl in
angular suddenly We have some
performance problems because it does not load
well or flat out like the thing is dying
page that is saturated and for that type
of scenarios we need to add a fix
and we have to just how to plan
How are we going to migrate it or if it is going to be
work with two frameworks at the same time
So that's something heavy that has
touched see that to repair a bug
you have to get up suddenly three
different repositories because they are
made with different frameworks and all
they rise with different types Well in
this case of instances But between them
They live together and communicate
So you have to be very careful there.
in How we work
architecture what frameworks state
They will support us and plan for the future
What are we going to add to it and what is it going towards?
where the product will evolve
because today we can start with
an mvp but if you want the product
make a change soon make a
Full migration is going to be complex AND
suddenly add another product
soon becomes inefficient and is not
well optimized Okay thanks
uh particularly with the fatigue of
frameworks and so many frameworks that go
leaving every day every hour every minute
eh I feel like it depends on the approximation
or the context in which one is if
You are in a large company so
particularly in my case we are more
of 300 developers getting their hands on it
to the same project because it is very complicated
come to do a migration of a
framework to a different one, that is,
practically to death
yeah but let's say that in the personal case
as a developer you can never
stay behind so I like it
think of it as the life cycle of
a product product the life cycle of
of a startup of a company everything has
a life cycle then it is always
like the Boom everyone is
using the valley of
death and then very few come back and
They are reborn And there they do stabilize Then
Let's say you get one as a stage
so early because it's cool
developer but let's say No
it will necessarily be sustainable in the
time then in short I usually
I usually wait for him to survive in the
valley of death and one says well it is
a little more stable and I can enter
experiment for s projects for things
as individuals and then
implement it one as another way eh
very professional
good for the fatigue issue
frameworks have to think about when
go choose a framework that is like
Start a relationship then eh or if
If they are going to choose that, a relationship
They have to know very well who they are with
they are going to mess with something or who they are going to mess with
marry eventually
So basically what I want
What I mean is that they do a very careful analysis
deep and project yourself into the future if this
this library this framework is
tool is really going to be viable
here in 5 10 20 years eh what my saying
mate eh everything everything has like its
life cycle then it is also like
interesting to look at tools that already
They are proven to be already robust eh
that they have already done and undone that already
They have many eh Books covered and so on
basically thank you
eh talking about relationships I think
that one can never know how
that one learns so much from people
knowing so much and the frameworks are
equal One at first does not know what
It's going to happen in 3 years so I think
What if, for example, you change libraries or
not even frameworks change libraries
inside react sometimes many times has
been very complex and it was up to us because
the bookstore was bought by another company or
It stopped working So yes I believe
that cannot be known. I believe that
important is one how to try
create how much flexibility you can and how
to go as I tell them, creating good
patterns creating as if each decision
in a more centralized way to be able
evaluate it and change it but yes I would say
that
as a decision for my career Me in
At no time have I thought, huh?
I'm going to learn this framework and learn
everything I would say no, it's more
important one learn to solve
problems and do useful things more than
make a perfect decision I had
lucky to learn react 5 years ago and
to continue working on it but then
really no I don't think that even in that
moment I would have known it was going to be the
ideal framework Okay good Many
thank you all for sharing your
knowledge with
us
Many
[Music]
thank you now yes good what
more than photo what
That's good, the logistics are going to be like this
super easy here at the bottom in my hand
right you are going to find one
big door that door already faces the street
and there they go to a lot of volunteers with
this shirt that will guide you and
arranging where we are going to take the photo
ready and for those who are watching me on
streaming as they are not going to be in the
photo, take a selfie and let us know
JC's social networks are tagged
so that we also include them
Now yes please from behind
Oh, be careful with the little cables.
run, don't push
but they are already opening the door
So we're going out there for the
photo Thank you very much, take care of them
eye translation devices
then they get in
you
[Music]
Oh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
and
oh
[Music]
Oh
oh
and
[Music]
oh
[Laughs]
[Music]
he
oh
[Music]
and
oh
[Music]
Oh
and
oh
[Music]
and
oh
Oh
[Music]
oh
Oh
[Music]
oh
and
Oh
[Music]
oh
and
[Music]
oh
bu
[Music]
and
oh
[Music]
ha
I have
Ho
[Music]
oh
g
[Music]
I have
oh
[Music]
and
Oh
[Laughs]
h
[Music]
oh
and
[Music]
oh
Oh
I have
oh
and
b
[Music]
and
Oh
[Music]
oh
and
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
T
oh
[Music]
bu
yes
[Music]
ha
oh
[Music]
I have
oh
[Music]
I have
h
oh
[Music]
and
oh
[Music]
and
oh
[Music]
g
Hey
[Music]
oh
and
[Music]
oh
ch
and
oh
[Music]
and
oh
[Music]
and
h
[Music]
Ho
oh
[Music]
I have
oh
[Music]
h
and
[Music]
oh
ch
[Music]
oh
Oh
Hello good
afternoons that it is noted that they had lunch
that they managed to have lunch, I'm
I'm going to go take a nap now but
well let's hope now that there is
opportunity I go for a couple of coffees
which is very good for
hold on until the end of the event
remember we close at 5
we leave the Auditorium and the After Party or
The little party is going to be outside So
we have something prepared for you
that we stay let's network
soon there are some things that we
we can take or
eat Let's continue with the
content of this and the second part
of day 2 of the J Colombia
2023 the last one we leave we continue with
local talent from Carmen de
Bolívar joins us to talk about
testing and different tools
testing Miguel Terán a round of applause for
Miguel for
[Applause]
favor
ready There we are good first
thank everyone who had lunch
quick to come see the talk here
thank jcom for the space and
well today precisely we are going to
talk about three tools
automation the most important in
this moment in the world the most
used in almost all languages
programming when do I use one when
I use the other one which is better than the other which one
It's faster that's what we're going to do
resolve today and hopefully they give us
the 15 minutes to be able to do that
analysis together first I have to
start by talking a little about
information that I am going to give here is
biased because I don't have the same
experience with selenium than with
other frameworks true and obviously Eh
Well I'm going to have much more knowledge
of selenium and I can talk to more
property but I prepared myself I investigated
I did everything to be able to bring you one
talk today playray 6 ago
months that I have been using it and in the
Simple Cypress case I was told in
With Miguel we approve your talk
I had to start studying cypres to
be able to make that comparison and understand
how did this framework work huh
selenium in particular I have worked on it
with python with csar and with javascript Like this
which has not only been with javascript I have
eh more experience in fact in python
what what with javascript but of all
ways I understand well how
works fine let's start with one
general table this general table suits us
to give a vision of the three frameworks
we can immediately realize
that the oldest is elenion the one who most
robust is elenion the most
bookstores has es elenion we could
say that the most used in the world very
it's probably selenium because it's old
which is very traditional however
both Cypress and playray have won
too much boom in recent years
Above all, highlight the player that
It was barely created in 20 20 it does not have
not even 4 years and he has filed a lawsuit
impressive eh. In the case of playr it was
created by Microsoft the other two
They were created more than anything by
community by a group of
developers in the case of celen eh
we highlight jason hugis there because
Well, he has always worked on this topic.
of automation And it was the ones that started
that project as such eh they are all Open
source and something very particular selenium
It was obviously made in Java because in
At that time Java was the reference and it was
where everything was done while
playwright and cypress es are written
in javascript the case of playr in
Ty Script is also used
ready what's up with Cypress cpress is very
particular because Cypress is a
complete automation framework
it has too many tools it's super
complete that is an advantage that is a
disadvantage everyone will take it their own
criterion is the same as what happens with reap
the first thing I do when I make a
reap project is to install redux
then I have to install reap router
then I have to build a bookstore for
do ccs then I have to do it in angular
It's not like that because Angular already brings me everything
That's it, Angular already comes with a framework
complete to do that that's what
what happens with Cypress in Cypress I don't
I install practically nothing I only install
the framework and it already brings me
absolutely everything but very important
en It should be noted that despite the robust
which is is designed for testing
m2n that is to say pre what happens if I want
try my
apis What happens if I want to try one
application of
desktop cannot be done. Then we have
Consider that when choosing the
tool with which we are going to
work and that's where we're going
seeing in the course of the talk a
very curious thing about Cypress is that
within its framework it brings Cypress
Studio that allows me to record tests I
I don't know code, I don't know how to program but
I know how the application works
I can record it, I do the steps in
the application and the test is recorded
Ready, that's one of the cool things that
has
well another table plus another analysis but
run level How can I
implement my tests in the case
for example playwright or selenium I can
use multiple languages
programming not only javascript I can
use csar can i use java in cpr
Only javascript because it is
focused on tests in your what
we had said only fren in the case of
e speed which is the most part
important here the fastest in this
moment it's playr and we're going to see it in
the demo is
extremely fast Not just fast
extremely fast and in the case of
Cypress for being such a robust framework
It is very slow and we will see it in the
demo also selen let's say it's in
midpoint between these two at the end
we could say that playr is a
framework too but it doesn't have all
the advanced features it has
Cypress playwright is a framework
modular then yes I want to add
I have to add certain things
with more libraries but in itself he is
super robust just making the template
base or starting with the basic part
Let's look at an example of this login that
we see here user password login and
I test that the login is successful How do I do it?
does that in selenium in Cypress in
playwright that's what we're going to review
So first let's start with Cypress
This is the simple code
extremely simple I don't have to
write absolutely nothing more than
You see there what I do, I navigate to the
application that I want to try is supposed to
that already renders the
user and password controls
I fill in the username and password I do
click on the button and then check
that this logo has actually been
rendered, that is, the homepage is already
super easy there and what do I use to do
that test look what c says and what it is
Cypress as such I mean I'm not
using a test library
additionally I only use Cypress
absolutely for everything and this is how it looks
execution What does cpress do Cypress opens
an awesome development environment
That's why it's so slow, I choose En
what browser do I want to try and it
run the test there as if it were
as if there is a true iframe there
loading the web page adds the
different data and the test passed that
that's the way it works
Cypress this can be reconfigured
they can do things so that he
default choose a browser many things
but I am showing by default what
he makes and the tools he provides
Now how do you do the same in
selenium obviously changes the code already
the code doesn't look so pretty
super complex What happens when one already
has a robust selenium project
This is not going to look like that because I
I start creating components I start
distribute my code and that remains a lot
smaller I simply do one of
all the configuration and that's already something
very curious about selenium is that I have
to always remove the browser for that reason
the crux is always down and that's something
that we do it through
true configuration creating as a
Script that always runs at the end
of each test So that's not going to
stay like this But again I am
showing how the test is done from
zero without library without configurations
but from scratch That's how it is, what is it?
what I like the most about selenium
keywords to bring the elements look
For example that
ID so I bring the element by ID by
class by name is super understandable and
super easy and the sen kis allows me
Well, send the text that I want to that one
component and this is how it is done. Let's say how the
try something very curious is elenion is
a bookstore, we had said it, seleni is
a library is not a framework then
everything I want to do I add
not another library that I'm trying with
Chrome look at it above we are using
selenium webdriver chrome that's a
library that allows me to generate the
Driver to connect to Chrome no longer
I want to try in Chrome now I want
try in Edge what do I do I install the
Ed's library and I import Ed now
no chrome ready library is same as
reap I add it I add it I add it and it
I build according to my needs
and this is what selenium looks like So
running look what I'm using
mpn test Why Because selenium like
such cannot Construct the proof but
you need a test library
also then with that with
We configure the test, what it does is
that takes control of the browser, look at that
It's very different than Cypress Takes Over
from the browser and there we see a
message that says this is being
controlled by a tool
automation and run the test there
ready very different Now what does playr do
playwright fixed a lot of the
problems we had with both
previous libraries code first
it's simple again
simplifies, look at the steps, super easy and
here all the framework that we are
using es playr again for that reason
It is a framework we do not add libraries
additional we do not add anything playr anymore
bring absolutely everything there and with that
we then do that review
now how to run playwright by
By default we execute this mpx command eh
playr test and the name of the test or
it could be look what they do open the
three browsers but it does so
fast that you can't see it
tested in all three browsers
at the same time hed F4 Chrome in less
2 seconds or 3 seconds How does he do it?
To make the test very easy it is
that when I install playwright he
It comes with some versions of the browsers
micro micro versions that are very O
They do not have all the configuration or the
features that Google Chrome has
or that Ed has but that he does have
rendering engine and with that
speeds up the test and that is why it is so
fast and I don't have to worry about it
version issue what happens with
selenium selenium as you saw
mounts on the browser when I
I install the library it comes with one
version And that version comes to light
browser What happens if I update my
Google Chrome because he asks me to
update and in selenium I have the
version 10.1 breaks your test because
He says I can't connect to that one anymore.
browser that browser is a version
different I don't understand it with playray
that will never ever happen because playr
Below you have the true browsers
and he controls them if I want
update the browser I update it
in playr anymore I don't update my browser
ready let's talk about this survey
We see here that survey was done by this
company called Ultimate qa cigars
automators and qa people ready eh
we see what selenium player they have
exactly eh the same eh well almost
the same scores all three are
extremely popular however here
surely we are not focusing only on
javascript then that's why
this one also has that rating
when we talk about popularity I'm going to
github what happens on github how
popular are it turns out look at that
graphic from there Look at the green and blue
see how the green has already surpassed the blue
green is playwright this means
which player is already being downloaded the most
that selenium itself despite being
so popular and so old because playr
It has a lot of demand from people. I mean
there is a lot of eh eh affection from the
community and that is what makes it
have 470 contributors and already have more
stars than Cypress himself and that
own selenium ready is happening what
the same thing that happens with rost that despite
that is so new is a language of
very loved and very useful programming
So playr definitely has
a lot of future will have a lot of support and
it will surely become a standard
future I'm sure it's going to suck
surpass all other frameworks
automation let's look at some
real scenarios to see if it gives us the
time eh Well what if I have a
team that only knows javascript
focused on usability is a team
small What would be the best bookstore
to work
then if they don't know of anything else
thing if not javascript if they are not
They may be Juniors, I would say good.
Let's go to Cypress Why Because
Cypress is a complete framework that already
It has everything and those people are not experts
programming is not an expert in
programming languages ​​my application
focuses on front not on backen on logic
I'm going to Cypress then playr then
selenium that would be the options that
from my personal experience
I would recommend then eh What if
we already have a javascript framework in
the brake but we have it in the back
different programming languages
I would recommend especially if we are
working with languages ​​like dot net
node and java that have been measured
modernizing the same python there yes me
I would definitely go for playwright
because most likely it's going to touch me
trying those apis and cpress does not work
So with playr I can try
whatever another scenario what if I
I have that framework but it turns out that in
the backend I have languages
less common programming that is already
they are letting it be used to make backen
like Ruby like per like php very
probably if I have to do
tests there because I would have to go
selenium why Because it is the only one that
has compatibility with those languages
programming ready and finally
we have what about an application
desktop with an application
desk is that it is made in En
electron what is useful to me all
They are really very bad at that, none of them
it's really good to do that kind
testing however Cypress has that
some support and the same Play rce
but they are very bad, they are in preview
and on the page you will find Which
They are the best options that they
really recommend for those
scenarios to finish conclusion
eh player is definitely the most
innovative they already realized the
speed with which you do things
can
containerized continuous integration very
easy eh selenium is the longest it is
the one that takes the longest if there is any
error or there is a problem let's
find a solution on the internet because
it takes a long time so there is a lot
people who work with those typers are the
more complete now for testing in tuen al
The final message is let's use what
It is more useful to us for the project than
we are working list
excellent Miguel Many
thank you very very good
We continue with more content I hope
have already learned how to do ui tests
I don't know absolutely anything about that Oh
thanks, I'm a backend developer and I do
I just had to do a Front project
I almost had to learn react. Better said
I sweat it all there but it only left me
more beautiful but I don't even have that
no idea
criterion we continue with talent
Latin American this time from Brazil
This is another person I also met
a long time ago in the community
javascript especially in the community
nojs we were quite a lot back then
when I was a collaborator on the project
Note 2018
2019 and in
conferences I was also approaching
I want to participate I want to contribute
I want to collaborate and the importance is
Show that wanting is power now this
person I am going to introduce is
amazing renowned educator
internationally
also contributes to the Open project
source dejs and has worked on some things
in the Incredible project like all the
native t testing theme note that
He worked a lot on that part in the
project and today he comes to tell us a
a lot of magic but I lost it
It disappeared Oh no, here it is my friend
As
you are then continuing with the Tour
international for
number
19 19 international conferences this
year this boy has been all over
world comes to talk to us
about How to manage gigabytes of data
without breaking the browser give a loud
applause and a hug, I'm going to give it to
er wendel
I would say I've been to a lot of
different conferences but Colombia is
different the Energy here is Crazy I
feel like home so Thank you so
much well I'm wearing this tshirt but I
don't socer Anymore I
Know so here I'm Tell I'm Going To Tell
you about javascript and my job nowadays
is to tell
people most The Old guys like I'm
classical old school that javascript is
not for this But I'm Going To prove that
We can do Whatever you want with
javascript with good performance and low
cost so This Is going to be
Great as Always I know This is a
lot of information to observe Okay so so
I want you to go at your home do a
homework so I I got a lot of different
resources for you Uh different
challenges for you to follow along and
please Take as many pictures As you can
Ok this helps me this helps the
Conference and this helps everyone to
Keep doing these conferences and
traveling out there all right so First
of all Thank you for the Translator
right I'm sure My English is not perfect
so I wonder what She's translating there
right
have to Translate toce right Okay
javascript jsc so I started with c sharp
And I start listening to a lot of people
said well
javascript isn't for real application
javascript is not a It's not a serious
Language I was like Okay if you say so
javascript is not multif threaded It was
like yeah but It's a bit different but
I've heard a lot so you shouldn't use CP
python Java they're Always been there
and why We are Going To choose
javascript Ok and javascript is Law Oh
my God This is low this It's going to
stuck your browser It's going to who's
Going To use javascript in the back
who's crazy enough for do well I've been
creating a bunch of Stuff with
javascript and javascript is It's in the
same way It's good but It's accessible
right I wouldn't say It's the best
Language Because we don't have this
such a Thing right right but It's good
Because It's Easy to Start and nowadays
the Api It's Crazy performant so I've
been doing a lot of content on my
Channel and I've been making a lot of
questions like How is linked works How
they analyzing my code To Know If I
should use V or const or How the web
socket protocol
works Why we Just use socket so I'm
To implement This and show trying All
the struggles so I would understand If
some framework has some Problem and I'm
Going To put you there I Always I have
recreated the nojs from Scratch to learn
How these things were behind the scenes
And I got a lot of assumptions from all
Those people have no idea what they
are Talking About they said javascript
is is not for That I was like well but
have you seen this New Api Oh no I Saw
javascript from 95 I was like Come on
You Don't even Listen What you're
talking right So let's get started I'm
Going To show you here a bunch of
examples as js is here to motivate you
to Push you Forward to Keep learning and
Keep studying Keep searching This is the
goal of this Talk okay So I'm Going To
Start Talking About no js and I would I
would mention no js But You can think
like browsers would work in the same way
and I'm Going To show how nojs we able
to shine into 09 When there are so many
other Uh good
options I'm Going To talk about web
streams has anyone worked with web
streams
before just a few hands
Nice I'm Going To show common mistakes
We are doing constantly When working
with javascript I'm Going To show you
real Word use cases when you just can
copy and paste examples to your real
World applications and starting making
more money using less resources I'm
Going To show you How to execute back
backround tasks using browsers using frs
and so much more and in my opinion the
most powerful feature that we have in
javascript which is asn generators and
iterators Ok to get started I'm Going To
show you a brief Because to understand
performance We must know how nojs and
How the browsers are handling Our code
okay So This is nojs Back In 2009 This
is if you can see by right the bottom
They are using puts right It's not cons
log so It's Pretty interesting How nojs
has been evolving and It's created to be
there So let's jump in the back right
let's understand How the word was Back
then so Back then Java were Pretty solid
right a bunch of different frameworks we
Saw ptp we Saw csp Which I started
working python we Saw Ruby ru Ros we Saw
Scala with Play framework and It's hard
to compete right Imagine Back then since
the 80s there are so many different
platforms and frameworks And then I was
like nojs has to be special I Don't Know
Something happened What happened so no
js in my opinion When I started learning
programming I Had a huge problem I Had
to learn csp I Had to learn sql server I
Had to learn html css and you try
are facing something like this my god
How I'm Going To learn all these Tools
at the same time I'm going to get crazy
I will never be good at this but
javascript with no js we Had the mean
stack right we could use no js for
server mon db for database javascript in
the browser and so on and so Forth but
This is my opinion right What Is
actually happening there is that no js
and javascript came with cleverness
execution module let's understand How It
was work Back then Back then usually
have a huge web server and this web
server like gigabytes of Data to Run
simple applications and the power for
each individual customer We have for
each individual request We have there we
Going To Have a small resource Group
right we're going to have a small piece
of Memory cpu and a thread that tracks
All the Life cycle of Those clients well
If I'm trying to schedule Memory for
each individual client there This Means
that If I want a concurrent users I'm
Going To Have to manually scale up
horizontally right I Had to put more
Memory more disc and sometimes during
Black Friday events you have like 50% of
your whole server in ID State You're not
using But You are waiting for spikes
events and this was something really
really Bad Back then so no js came Up
was actually a proof of concept I talked
to Ryan in another Conference he was
like I never thought this was something
good I was Just trying out and it turned
out was Game changing for the whole
Industry Ok How nojs works instead of
Getting New compensation groups or New
schedule Memory locating Memory nojs
uses Ay Loop I'm Going To Tell you Uh
How it's work later but Imagine that we
schedule the amount of Memory on the
nojs startup so I have the just a small
Group to handle What the operations
System is going to need How I'm going to
read files and How I'm Going To put All
the customers on a list let's say the
list so Now when I'm doing request I'm
Going To put all Those Those clients in
right I'm Going To put them all in this
Kill But I'm not more Memory I'm Going
To use and reuse the same Memory have
What's the point Now now I have all
Those customers That I say well I Want
To insert This Data on the database so
I'm Going To Have someone Which we call
l in this Case that is going to schedule
events to your operating System and When
the operating system is ready he just
said well well call him Back and answer
the the question But You Are Not holding
anyone in Memory you Just sing in
trining events so this was Pretty Pretty
Amazing for that then so if you don't
remind remember anything I said no js
the cool thing is you don't need to
allocate memory for each individual
client This is Why you can but you
shouldn't use a raspberry pi server to
Run your servers right This is Why we
can use free tis on Uh Back then heroku
or other Cloud platforms spending very
fewer resources to deliver Our
applications and on the panel Raphael
said nojs has threads right people Come
To Me I've seen so often well javascript
doesn't have thread was like Yeah yeah
You're right javascript is Nothing
javascript is just an abstraction that
We are translating for something that is
going to Run on your Machine Whatever in
nojs is c+ but nojs has Always been
working with threads if you Look at the
docs a lot of text here but let's Just
get the the important thing we use
threads for expensive tasks which is io
intensive When I handle dns When I have
file System apis I have to call uh uh
How how the operating system is working
cpu If I have to work with crypto
compressing file and
Everything Ok Now I'm more confused and
Ever Why people say that nojs doesn't
have threads Why people Say that
javascript or nojs is single threaded
well actually nojs exposed a library a
library no a module in the 19 version
so Now you as a user can Spin up threads
but we don't we don't Spin up threads
for each individual customer we usually
create a po of threads so we can process
images process videos all background for
cpu intensive test but It was Always
Being there
nice but answer the question the Part
The Only Part which is single thread in
nojs is the event Loop and you can think
of W true that is handling the order of
the execution that is going to make sure
that we don't change twice the same ver
the same Memory or the same address so
Este
Amazing
Okay We are here to process gigabytes of
Data using javascript I won to you I
have current projects running with this
that we going to try out at home but
yeah This is Amazing so I'm here in the
browser okay I'm Going To click here and
I'm Going To Select a 7 gab file I'm
going to read this file a video and I'm